einen schönen guten morgen schön dass
sie bei uns sind wir gehen live mit zdf
heute live an einem bedeutsamen tag für
deutschland denn heute endet eine ära
und es beginnt etwas neues nach 16
jahren angela merkel wählt der bundestag
heute einen neuen bundeskanzler und der
wird aller voraussicht nach olaf scholz
heißen wir werden das in den nächsten
stunden begleiten bei uns verpassen sie
nichts von der abstimmung bis zur
vereidigung hier sehen wir die bilder im
bundestag ist schon mächtig was los der
fühlt sich schon und wir haben spannende
gesprächspartner innen es sind vor allem
viele die journalisten und deutschland
3000 moderatorin eva schulz wird bei uns
sein der designierte spd generalsekretär
kevin kühn andrea schröder von der fdp
wir werden die opposition höheren ronja
kemmer cdu frei ist future sprecherin
annika riedmann den journalisten und die
da oben moderator jan schippmann und
außerdem gebäude zdf hauptstadtstudio
kompetenz live aus dem bundestag nicole
diekmann
morgen da bist du nicht schön dass auch
heute wieder bei uns bist du wirst uns
wie immer deine einschätzung und infos
mit uns teilen und später wirst du dann
auch mit den politikerinnen und
politikern sprechen die dann bei dir
vorbei kommen also sie sehen es gibt
viel zu besprechen heute morgen wir
wollen uns auch dafür viel zeit nehmen
deshalb schreiben sie uns ihre fragen
gerne in die kommentarspalten oder
schicken sie uns eine mail die sie jetzt
eingeblendet sehen wir versuchen soviel
wie geht davon zu beantworten und auch
zu diskutieren nicole als spd grüne und
fdp gestern dann offiziell den
koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet haben da
hat olaf scholz gesagt es soll ein
morgen sein an dem wir aufbrechen spürst
du von diesem spirit morgen irgendwas im
bundestag oder ist es eher so business
as usual
also nun wirklich nicht hier ist
tatsächlichen
ausnahmezustands tag kann man sagen das
hat sich ganz praktisch mal aus dem
leben einer reporterin zu berichten
darin äußert dass ich hier am reichstag
ankam und so eine lange schlange vor der
einlasskontrolle noch nie gesehen habe
das liegt nicht an corona hier wird
natürlich der impfstatus auch alle die
dieses hohe haus betreten kontrolliert
das wird es aber schon etwas länger
sondern es liegt an diesem tag um mich
herum ich stehe hier auf der pläne ein
team reiht sich an das andere ein
fernsehteam es sind sehr sehr viele
journalistinnen und journalisten hier im
haus ich glaube nicht nur diejenigen die
wirklich auch aktuell berichten sondern
auch diejenigen für die sowas ja wie
eine fußball-wm ist also für politik
interessierte ist das ja heute
unglaublich wichtiger tag so richtig
spannend ist er nicht wie gehe ja
wirklich alle davon aus dass es olaf
scholz wird aber 16 jahre dass es eben
selber gesagt es endet eine ära
das ist ein politischer umbruch
personell zumindest erstmal inhaltlich
werden wir sehen und sag mal was gerade
angesprochen wie läuft das heute im
bundestag ab was gilt aktuell 2 g.de 2g
plus und es wird mit sicherheit doch
auch wieder zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auf den tribünen geben wie es sonst
üblich war
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer werden hier
seien genau es gilt für die abgeordneten
gilt 3g
für uns auch das heißt aller voraussicht
nach werden auch wieder mitglieder der
fdp bundestagsfraktion wie ja schon seit
beginn dieser regelung hier auf der
tribüne setzen die sich weigern auskunft
darüber zu geben welchen status sie
haben die im chinesen oder getestet
heute ist ein großer tag mit auch nicht
so ganz unkomplizierten abläufen
parlament schloss bellevue hin und
zurück und wir können kurz durchgehen
was heute alles passieren wird nikolai
ag hat dass wir uns zusammengefasst
ist scholz heute mittag wirklich
bundeskanzler ist gibt es am vormittag
noch einiges an hin und her es beginnt
um 9 uhr am bundestag dort wird die wahl
des neuen bundeskanzler stattfinden der
neue bundestag hat insgesamt 736 sitze
für die wahl des kanzlers muss eine
mehrheit aller mitglieder des
bundestages zustimmen also 369 die neue
ampelkoalition hat insgesamt 416 stimmen
scholz kann sich also maximal 47
abweichler in den koalitionsreihen
leisten wenn scholz gewählt ist geht es
um 10 uhr 30 zum schloss bellevue wo er
vom bundespräsidenten die
ernennungsurkunden erhält vor vier
jahren als schatz zum bundesminister
ernannt wurde war das ganze so aus
weiter geht es für scholz um 12 uhr
wieder im bundestag wo er als
bundeskanzler vereidigt werden soll
damit ist das hin und her noch nicht
beendet anschließend geht es für alle
künftigen minister innen zum
bundespräsidenten und mit der
ernennungsurkunde zurück in den
bundestag zur vereidigung des kabinetts
und genau das werden wir den ganzen
vormittag begleiten du wirst bei uns
sein nicole und vielleicht wenn wir mal
ein bild aus dem bundestag zeigen da
sieht man jetzt auch noch kanzlerin
merkel vielleicht können wir das kurz
sie spricht hier und heute ist das denn
genau dann kann
wir leben ja die situation dass angela
merkel in kein bundestagsmandat mehr hat
sie wird dann oben auf den oberen rängen
platz nehmen oder wie läuft das dieses
mal ab
gute frage sie hat ja wie du gerade
gesagt hast kein mandat mehr das heißt
sie kann olaf scholz auch nicht wer
also wahrscheinlich wird sie auf der
tribüne platz nehmen das nehme ich
ansagen was mal so
wichtige anschlusstermin hat sie
vielleicht heute nicht bevor scholz auch
den bundestag hier dann als gewählter
kanzler ja voraussichtlich verlässt dann
findet zwischen den beiden vielleicht
noch eine übergabe statt aber dann war
es das für angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin
absolut und wir haben es jetzt auch
gerade eben sehen können wie du richtig
gesagt hast hat sie auf den oberen
rängen platz genommen sie ist nicht
unten im kleiner saal nicole oder freut
dass jetzt noch nicht mal offiziell
gewählt da schweige dann vereidigt da
wird er schon als krisen kanzler
bezeichnet es gab ja durchaus wirklich
schon vorgängerin und also eine
vorgängerin und einige vorgänger die
leichtere ausgangsbedingungen haben
ich höre dich leider nicht mehr des ik
kannst du mir die frage noch mal stellen
ja die stelle ich dir gerne nochmal kann
ziemlich denn jetzt hören danke hier ist
es laut ok ich jetzt höre ich der
wunderbar ich meinte gerade das ist olaf
scholz er bis jetzt weder offiziell
gewählt noch vereidigt ist aber schon
länger und ihn in den medien den krisen
kanzler genannt und das ist ja wirklich
angela merkel oder eben auch ihre
vorgänger leichter hatten bessere
ausgangsbedingungen hatten
das kann man wohl sagen also olaf scholz
übernimmt hier die amtsgeschäfte in der
vierten welle mitten in der vierte
corona welle die ja viel brachialer
dramatischer ist als die drei
vorhergehenden deutschland befindet sich
gerade in der situation dass in dieser
woche ausgerechnet in dieser woche in
der die ampel tatsächlich in amt und
würden kommt hier noch mal nachgebessert
wird und zwar in eilig anberaumten
sondersitzung in bezug auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz das hatte die
ampel wie gesagt die noch nicht
vereidigt ist die die amtsgeschäfte noch
nicht aufgenommen hat da war die ampel
schon mal dran im november war man schon
mal an diesem gesetz dran da gab es sehr
viel kritik das seien zu wenige nicht
weit greifende nicht genug weit
greifende maßnahmen und nun bessert man
tatsächlich noch mal nach gestern erster
lesung hier im bundestag am donnerstag
zweite und dritte und dann am freitag
sondersitzung im bundesrat also diese
100 tage schonfrist die man ja
normalerweise einer neuen regierung
einräumt ich glaube davon kann sich die
ampel schon direkt zum einstieg hier
verabschieden denn dafür ist die zeit
einfach nicht da die lage ist
tatsächlich sehr ernst und der
handlungsbedarf ist sehr hoch
absolut und das wende auch im laufe der
sendung noch weiter vertiefen nicole du
bleibst bei uns und jetzt möchte ich die
journalisten und deutschland 3000
moderatorin eva schulz begrüßen ich
hoffe sie ist jetzt bei uns halo mit
einem schönen guten morgen ich
höre leider nichts
und ich glaube sie hat mich nichts sonst
wir gehen dann wieder zurück zu nicole
diekmann
in den bundestag der sich jetzt auch
schon ordentlich gefüllt hat nicole wir
sind wieder bei dir die samenleiter tod
probleme mit eva schulz schauen wir mal
in den chats da
schreibt ein user sorry aber ich hatte
noch nie so wenig vertrauen in unsere
politiker wie jetzt momentan gilt nicht
die devise wer ist die beste wahl um uns
zu vertreten sondern wer richtet den
geringsten schaden an
das ist natürlich nur niederschmetternde
diagnose wenn ich das so sagen darf und
mal im corona bild zu bleiben
das ist ein vertrauensverlust gibt das
ist evident dass wissen wir das zeigen
umfragen dass bringt auch die stimmung
gut auf den punkt die im moment herrscht
es gab einfach in den vergangenen
monaten viel hickhack fangen wir damit
an
impfzentren wurden abgeschafft nun
müssen sie ganz eilig wieder
hochgefahren werden impfempfehlungen wie
zum beispiel boostern ja oder nein es
gab erst die empfehlung ab 70 dann gab
es die empfehlung ab 60 dann gab es den
einwand der politik wir müssen da wir
müssen da tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen
gas geben jetzt ist es für alle es wird
sehr umständlich kommuniziert teilweise
widersprüchlich kommuniziert nicht
deutlich kommuniziert nicht klar
kommuniziert dass das eine das andere
ist dass es ein
naja geführtes machtvakuum gab in den
letzten wochen die groko ist ja auch
jetzt noch geschäftsführend im amt die
ampel ist noch nicht im amt und das hat
zum einen so eine kleine
lähmungserscheinungen bei einigen
hervorgerufen was entscheidungen angehen
und zum anderen haben es aber auch
einige parteifunktionäre benutzt um das
schwarze peter spiel zu spielen wie
einige sagen und das ist mitten in einer
pandemie mitten in einer massiven
dramatischen vierten welle nicht die
zeit dafür das heißt da haben viele
enttäuschungen stattgefunden bei bürgern
auch stichwort impfpflicht das hin und
her die man ja kategorisch
ausgeschlossen hatte explizit
ausgeschlossen hatte und die nun doch
kommen soll also da ist einiges
kaputtgegangen ja das stimmt
nicole während du sprichst sehen wir die
bilder aus dem plenarsaal und wir gucken
auf die uhr es ist acht uhr 59 um 9 uhr
soll die sitzung eröffnet werden und
wenn man das ganze puzzle sieht dann
stellt man sich tatsächlich die frage ob
das so pünktlich klappen wird ob dann
auch alle auf ihren plätzen sitzen
vielleicht bis dahin ein kurzes
rechenspiel spd grüne und fdp stellen
insgesamt
416 von
736 abgeordneten olaf scholz bräuchte
also demnach
369 stimmen wermes ihm gehört er könnte
sich also 47 abweichler leisten denkst
du dass es soweit kommen wird
ist die große frage das ist die große
frage ich habe ja eben schon den
vergleich gezogen dass wir uns leute die
wir unsere politik interessieren das
heute so was ist wie das finale der
fußball weltmeisterschaft und da ist
eben ja auch das ergebnis wichtig wie
geht jetzt mal davon aus dass olaf
scholz diese wahl gewinnt also dass er
diese erforderlichen 369 stimmen auf
sich vereint aber ist wirklich die frage
gibt es abweichler gibt es vielleicht
leute aus der eigenen ampel die sich
denken jetzt hab ich mir irgendwie
anders vorgestellt das hätte jemand
anderes besser gekonnt den gebe ich
meine stimme nicht es wird spannend wir
sehen jetzt gerade das im plenarsaal
sich alle erheben und jetzt doch alle
relativ schnell auf ihre plätze gehen
deshalb
gehen wir jetzt mal rüber und schauen
uns die eröffnung an
liebe gäste sehr verehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen einen
schönen guten morgen die sitzung ist
eröffnet
ich begrüße auf der ehrentribüne die
geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin frau
dr angela merkel
[Applaus]
weiterhin begrüße ich auch ehemalige
repräsentantinnen und repräsentanten der
verfassungsorgane
seine exzellenz den apostolischen
nuntius und alle weiteren gäste die auf
den tribünen platz genommen haben
herzlich willkommen
damit rufe ich den tagesordnungspunkt 2
auf die wahl des bundeskanzlers der herr
bundespräsident hat mir hierzu
mitgeteilt gemäß artikel 63 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland schlage ich dem deutschen
bundestag vor herrn olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler zu wählen
[Applaus]
ich bitte nun um ihre aufmerksamkeit für
einige hinweise zum wahlverfahren die
wahl findet mit verdeckten stimmzetteln
also geheim statt gewählt ist wer die
stimmen der mehrheit der mitglieder des
bundestages also mindestens 369 stimmen
erhält für diese wahl benötigen sie
ihren blauen wahlausweis aus ihrem
stimmkarten fach in der west lobby die
abgeordneten auf den tribünen haben oder
werden noch ihre wahlausweise vom
plenar- assistenzdienst erhalten bitte
kontrollieren sie ob der ort wahlausweis
auch ihren eigenen namen trägt die
abgeordneten hier unten im plenarsaal
werden in der abgeordneten lobby wählen
gehen sie zum wählen bitte erst nach
aufruf ihres namens nicht
alle auf einmal
in der abgeordneten lobby erhalten sie
an den alphabetischen alles an den
ausgabe zwischen eine blaue stimmkarte
und auch den amtlichen
wahlumschlag die abgeordneten auf der
tribüne werden auf der tribüne neben
wählen dort befinden sich auch ein
ausgabe tisch für die genannten
wahlunterlagen sowie eine wahlkabine
gültig sind nur stimmen mit einem kreuz
bei ja
nein oder enthalte mich ungültig sind
stimmen auf nicht amtlichen stimmkarten
sowie stimmkarten die mehr als ein kreuz
kein kreuz andere namen oder zusätze
enthalten sie dürfen ihre stimmkarten
uhr in der wahlkabine ankreuzen und sie
müssen ebenfalls noch in der wahlkabine
die stimmkarte in den umschlag legen die
schriftführerin und schriftführer sind
verpflichtet jeden der seine stimmkarte
außerhalb der wahlkabine kennzeichnet
oder in den umschlag legt zurückzuweisen
die stimmabgabe kann in diesem fall
jedoch vorschriftsmässig wiederholt
werden nachdem sie die stimmkarte in
eine wald in eine der wahlkabinen
gezeichnet und dort in den wahlumschlag
gelegt haben gehen sie bitte zu den
wahlurnen
bevor sie den wahlumschlag in einer der
wahlurne werfen müssen sie ihren
wahlausweis einer der schriftführerin
oder einem der schriftführer an der
wahlurne übergeben der nachweis der
teilnahme an der wahl kann nur durch die
abgabe des wahl- ausweises erbracht
werden das fotografieren oder filmen der
ausgefüllten stimmkarten stellt einen
verstoß gegen das wahlgeheimnis
und verletzt die ordnung und würde des
hauses für den fall dass ich von solchen
verstößen gegen das wahlgeheimnis in
dieser sitzung oder auch später kenntnis
erhalten
behalte ich mir vor
ordnungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
ich bitte jetzt die eingeteilten
schriftführerin und schriftführer die
vorgesehenen plätze einzunehmen
ich bitte sie den namensaufruf zu
verfolgen und sich nach aufruf ihres
namens zur entgegennahme der stimmkarte
und des wahl- umschlages zu den ausgabe
tischen zu begeben
haben alle schriftführerinnen
schriftführer ihre plätze in der
abgeordneten lobby eingenommen
das ist der fall
ich eröffne die wahl und bitte mit dem
aufruf der nahmen zu beginn
liebe kollegen kollegen nach von unserer
seite einen wunderschönen guten morgen
wir fangen an china ab die
valentin abel
klude abraham
katja adler
stefanie effner
dies ahmatovic
türkei akbulut
7 aller bali radovan
stephan albani
ali al dailami
mohammad al hanak
renate als
norbert maria altenkamp
philipp amthor
luise amtsberg
dittmer andre
niels annen
johannes eidt
christine aschenberg-dugnus
andreas autor
artur auernhammer
peter aumer
mike außendorf
tobias bächle
caroline bachmann
lisa bloom
heike behrens
annalena baerbock
ulrike bahr
daniel baldi
felix donnerstag dorothee bär
karl der
hitze hat baradar
thomas bareiß
sören bartol
dr dietmar bartsch
also die abstimmung hat begonnen in
geheimer wahl und das kann jetzt ein
bisschen dauern denn wie gesagt
736 abgeordnete müssen ihre stimme
abgeben und deshalb freue ich mich dass
es jetzt geklappt hat dass wir mit
journalisten und deutschland 3000
moderatorin eva schulz sprechen können
guten morgen eva guten morgen schön dass
uns heute ein stückchen begleiten wird
auf dieser strecke du hattest ja
gelegenheit in deinem podcast mit allen
drei kanzler kandidatinnen ausführlich
zu sprechen wie hast du olaf scholz
damals erlebt
naja also dieser ruf vom schock so
marten der kommt ja nicht von irgendwo
dass das habe auch ich erlebt als
interviewerin dass er gerne sehr lange
sehr ausführliche vorsichtige antworten
gibt und jetzt nicht so super konkret
oder das an beispielen illustriert
stattdessen hat er lieber beispiele
genannt von bisherigen erfolgen die er
so verzeichnen konnte als regierender
weiß und hamburg oder als minister
das war jetzt schon nicht so leicht als
interviewerin da irgendwie mal ein
bisschen eine andere seite von ihm
hervorzubringen und hat das für das
gefühl dass hier das an der einen oder
anderen stelle mal geglückt ist dass er
da quasi nicht durch geflutscht ist
naja ich hab dann er
also wir haben natürlich über die
kritischen punkte gesprochen so was von
wirecard oder comics da kennt man aber
seine antworten ja auch sehr ausreichend
sind sehr also da denn wirklich so seine
fragen die ja wiederholt was ein
bisschen er gelungen ist dann noch mal
so eine persönlichere seite von ihnen zu
zeigen also ging man zum beispiel um
seine schulzeit war sagt er war super
unsportlich und ist dann oft als letzter
irgendwelche mannschaften gewählt worden
das ist ja heute anders das zählt ja
auch immer dass er verschiedene
sportarten betreibt sie sehr gerne rad
fährt und so weiter da fiel es ihm
leichter sich ein bisschen lockerer zu
machen das thema wirecard ist
tatsächlich auch ein größeres bei uns im
chat da gibt es verschiedene
kommentare susi schreibt scholz wird
korruption vorgeworfen ist da was dran
bis heute nicht geklärt
rennen möchte fragen wann herr scholz
für seine beteiligung an den
finanzskandalen zur rechenschaft gezogen
wird da gibt es tatsächlich
einige kommentare auch zu und wie war
das nach welchen gesprächen hast du dann
damals gedacht der oder die wirtschaft
oder wer dann warnung ein gefühl dafür
entwickeln können gar nicht und ja auch
zum glück weil sich das ja im rahmen
dieser bundestagswahl dieses wahlkampfs
immer wieder geändert hat nun also wenn
wir beide jetzt vor sagen wir mal neun
monaten gesprochen hätten wäre
wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht ist heute
herr scholz sehr wahrscheinlich zum
kanzler gewählt würde und das finde ich
auch ganz spannend dass der ja der
kandidat war der mit abstand als erster
fest stand und deshalb ganz lange
eigentlich sehr die füße still gehalten
hat und gar nicht so wirklich wahlkampf
gemacht hat sondern einfach ja einfach
schon somit lief und deshalb glaube ich
auch in den zeitlang von uns als
journalistin journalistin unterschätzt
wurde
und du hattest in deinem gespräche auch
danach gefragt ob es jetzt nicht an der
zeit wäre die klima bazooka auszupacken
eben in anspielung damals an die
finanz besucher die er ausgepackt hat da
ging es um die korona hilfen hattest du
da den eindruck dieses thema klimaschutz
klimarettung steht ganz oben auf seiner
liste wir werden ja später dann noch
annika rittmann von frasdorf user hören
wo ich mal davon ausgehen würde die hat
eine ganz spezielle meinung dazu aber
welchen eindruck hast du damals
nein ganz oben auf der liste von olaf
scholz und diesem wahlkampf stand
soziale gerechtigkeit das ist auch keine
überraschung bei der spd hat immer den
mindestlohn genannt er hat auch die
höhere besteuerung von besonders reichen
deutschen genannt die jetzt nicht so
wirklich im koalitionsvertrag gelangt
ist dafür aber der mindestlohn das ist
also ein erfolg für ihn und das war ihm
ganz wichtig und dann natürlich immer
dieses große thema respekt und was er
nicht so richtig geschafft hat was ihr
die klimabewegung oft schockiert ist das
aber soziale gerechtigkeit um
klimagerechtigkeit ganz eng miteinander
verwoben sind und noch stärker verbunden
sein werden in der zukunft
und dieser koalitionsvertrag jetzt ist
glaube ich in ein
punkten ein guter das thema angeht weil
er viele dinge messbar macht also gerade
wenn es um die ausbauziele für
erneuerbare angeht da hat sich diese
regierung ja ziele gesteckt die wir als
journalisten journalisten aber auch als
bürgerinnen und bürgern werden nach
halten können ist das wirklich gelungen
in vier jahren aber zum beispiel was den
verkehr angelangt wird das jetzt sehr
spannend mit dem verkehrsminister volker
wissing von der fdp
und dann sind auch solche ambitionen wie
von den grünen das ist ein klima veto
geben müsse für das jedes
gesetzesvorhaben einmal quasi auch die
klimaverträglichkeit gecheckt wird das
ist jetzt nicht durchgekommen deswegen
das wird spannend was die klimapolitik
dieses kanzlers und diese regierung
angelangt wie intensiv oder wie stark
die möglich wird
dazu ein kommentar auf youtube da
schreibt jemand er wird wohl der
emotionslose sste langweiligste kanzler
deutschlands aber hoffentlich bekommt er
die an gepackten ziele auch umgesetzt so
viel zu der art und weise wie olaf
scholz dann bei dem einen oder anderen
auch rüberkommt aber würdest du sagen
ist der koalitionsvertrag aus deiner
sicht einer der sich auch speziell an
die jüngere generation im land richtet
ich finde dass für die jüngere
generation und für vor allem viele
verschiedene gruppen in dieser jungen
generation auf jeden fall sachen drin
sind in diesem koalitionsvertrag eine
große stärken
große stärke dieser vertrag
gesellschaftspolitischen auf die politik
im familien
darüber oder nein
also das ist glaube ich eine diesem fund
und insbesondere für junge menschen sind
solche sinken dinge drin wie die
legalisierung von cannabis aber auch die
reform des bafögs systems habe ich
richtig richtig viele junge menschen
betreffen wird das wird ein ganz
vielerlei hinsicht reformiert und dann
hat diese regierung ja auch vorher oder
würde gerne das wahlalter absenken auf
16 das könnte allerdings schwierig
werden weil man dafür eben noch die
größere mehrheit mobilisieren muss über
diese drei fraktionen hinaus und das
grundgesetz zu ändern
wir schauen
mal in den chat
gute frage zur corona politik wenn
politiker sprechen aufgrund
unvorhergesehener ereignisse wieder
rufen dürfen dürfen wir dann auch unsere
wählerstimmen widerrufen fragt jemand
eine grundgesetzänderung
das geht nicht ich glaube es kommt da
vor allem auf kommunikation an und das
ist schon in den koalitionsverhandlungen
gemerkt so gestand anders abgelaufen
dafür dass auch den letzten 16 jahren
kann nämlich sehr verdeckter wurde
erstmal kompletten der verschlossene tür
ohne irgendetwas durchzusprechen
verhandelt und dann ganz am schluss nach
vorne getrieben in die öfen beschreibt
die frage ist also die regierung jetzt
muss ich dann bald
legt kommunizieren sie es mit uns als
bevölkerung und das ist natürlich eine
herausforderung gerade in dieser krise
haben wir auch in den letzten anderthalb
jahren gesehen haben manche sachen
verschoben aufgeschoben werden zugunsten
von kirche dringenden problem ist dass
man viel trinken auf jeden fall nämlich
aktuellen problem da bin ich gespannt
was uns prägen wird weil ja auch viele
kommentatoren und kommentatoren sagen ja
auch rentiert sich da eigentlich schon
ziemlich an der kanzlerin gerade wurde
optimiert emotionslos dass wir sie auch
um
liebe eva vielen dank an dieser stelle
erst mal und wir geben jetzt noch mal
rüber in den bundestag zu nicole
diekmann ich höre sie hat einen
gesprächspartner bitte schön
dass sie da sind
ist verständlich es tun das ist die
blaue karte okay
dann muss man vorzeigen damit klar ist
dass man stimmberechtigt ist und dann
gegen einen wahlzettel auf dem main olaf
scholz ja stimmt
wenn man in der ampel ist und dann wirft
man dass ein vielleicht noch ein paar
andere also sie glauben er wird
mindestens die erfordert mindestens die
416 stimmen kriegen aus der die ampel
besteht alle werden ihn wählen ich kann
nur für meine partei sprechen in meiner
partei über den selbstständig wählen wir
haben einen vertrag miteinander
vereinbart der beinhaltet inhalte aber
auch personalien und wir werden
natürlich liefern da wo es verabredet
ist und dazu gehört auch dass wir
geschlossen 100 spielen
warten wir mal ob das ob das auch so
kommt 416 stimmen gab es schon ein paar
mal gesagt man kann es nicht oft genug
sagen herr direktor das ist ein
besonderer tag die grünen kehren nach 16
jahren zurück in eine bundesregierung
sind sie super zufrieden oder ist auch
so ein gefühl dabei war ja nicht alles
in den koalitionsvertrag reingekommen
ist was die grünen sollten es gibt ein
tempolimit das verkehrsministerium geht
an die fdp vor dem kohleausstieg vor
2030 steht ein relativierende
idealerweise ist das so fifty fifty also
erstens haben wir 16 jahre opponiert und
werden wenn das funktioniert was ich
natürlich hoffe ich ausgehe ab heute
regieren das ist ein schöner tag für uns
nach einem historischen
bundestagswahlergebnis mit zweitens
haben wir sehr schwierige
koalitionsverhandlungen teilweise
geführt weil wir eine andere dynamik in
den reformen wollen weil wir in eine
andere geschwindigkeit notwendigkeit zu
machen als wäre alles ja aber mit denen
wir gesprochen als alle beide als die
fdp und auch als die spd das ist
zuweilen so das kann man so pauschal ich
sagen das ist von feld zu feld
unterschiedlich aber dass wir unser
programm nicht 100 prozent durchgesetzt
haben das nennt man koalition das gehört
sich so dass man kompromisse macht das
ist der wesenskern von demokratie ja
gerade im verkehrsbereich hätten wir uns
mehr gewünscht wir glauben dass die
verkehrswende notwendig ist um eine
klimaschutz voranzutreiben aber unter
dem strich wenn du jetzt zum beispiel
der kohle 2030 steht der kohleausstieg
dann ist das ein zugeständnis was die
spd gemacht hat olaf scholz hat noch
einen tag vor der wahl gesagt 23 38 wird
nicht gerüttelt aber mit einem so späten
kohleausstieg wie wir die klimaziele
nicht hin und deshalb sind wir jetzt
doch um einiges vorangekommen in den
koalitionsverhandlungen klimaschutz naja
aber idealerweise zuletzt ja ein auch
die 2030 oder vor 2030 zu früh finden
auch noch spielraum können dazu ich kann
das erklären idealerweise steht da weil
es natürlich darum geht das auch noch am
ende des tages strom aus der steckdose
kommen muss und deshalb müssen wir den
ausbau der erneuerbaren
selbstverständlich vorantreiben und
beschleunigen und dass das jetzt auch
mit einem fingerschnipsen passieren das
ist nicht gesagt und deshalb steht
dieser satz drin aber ich gehe davon aus
dass der kohleausstieg 20 30 kommt wir
werden sehen
im koalitionsvertrag 177 seiten ist er
stark stehen ja viele dinge aber es kann
natürlich nicht alles drin stehen im
koalitionsvertrag von vor vier jahren
stand ja auch nicht wie wir gegen die
pandemie vorgehen wollen er wusste
nämlich keiner dass corona uns
irgendwann ereilen würde
wenn wir in noch mal vier jahre gehen
wir davon aus dass die rampe vier jahre
lang hält und regiert was würden sie in
vier jahren sagen wofür sollen die
grünen neben klima gestanden haben was
ist so das augenmerk wo sie drauf gucken
wo sie sagen bei einem kompromissen bei
1 unwägbarkeiten da müssen wir uns
selber treu bleiben das ist das was wir
erfüllen müssen eine ampel regierung
geht erstens nicht darum dass jetzt die
grünen rausgehen und nach jedem
kompromiss sagen hey wir haben gewonnen
sondern das land muss gewinnen die
kompromisse müssen für alle gut tragbar
seien das zweite ist wir haben eine
riesige flotte an großen
herausforderungen ist es sehr viel zu
tun die klimakrise die pandemie haben
sie ja genannt wir haben eine
internationale unordnung sie bedrohlich
ist wir haben eine spaltung in der
gesellschaft die unsere demokratie
bedroht das heißt all das muss gepflegt
werden wir müssen die pandemie hierzu
den griff bekommen alsbald es geht wir
müssen die einen beitrag leisten zur
internationalen ordnung und frieden wir
müssen natürlich die klimaschutz
vorantreiben und wir müssen diese
gesellschaft versöhnen und
zusammenbringen die gesellschaft politik
wird auch dort eine riesige rolle
spielen daran werden muss wissen lassen
müssen stichwort versöhnen es gab in
ihrer partei jetzt als es um die
besetzung der ministerien ging gerangel
um zwar freundlich zu formulieren das
war ja offen zu sehen also die alten
gräben oder der alte graben reales und
fundis ist noch mal aufgebrochen wie
wollen sie denn das wieder kitten in den
nächsten jahren was da passiert das in
den letzten wochen wir haben insgesamt
wenn man auch noch den vorschlag eu
kommission und die
kulturstaatsministerin dazu 10 7 posten
zugesprochen bekommen dass es gut wir
haben mehr als sieben posten leute die
diese posten ausfüllen können das ist da
gerade verletzungen gibt es normal gab
es auch in der spd auch in der fdp der
anton hofreiter gesehen hat bei uns war
es nur draußen bei uns was quasi die
gefallen mir gesagt sichtbar die
sichtbarkeit war der unterschied auch in
der union da bist immer also kabinett
posten besetzt haben verletzungen und
jetzt ich verstehe total gut dass
hofreiter und chören der kdd fraktion
gut und lange geführt haben anspruch auf
ministeramt erhoben haben das ist am
ende anders gekommen jetzt werden wir
diese wunden miteinander lecken müssen
und auch miteinander dafür arbeiten dass
wir jetzt erfolg haben in der regierung
nur zusammen beides schaffen
wenn alles so läuft wie sie sich das
wünschen werden sie ja einer der neuen
beiden parteichefs seien sie und ricarda
lang sind ja im gespräch
nochmal dieser graben zwischen fundis
und realos man hat ja die letzten jahre
gedacht er ist zugeschüttet ist ja ganz
offensichtlich nicht ich fand die
körpersprache von anton hofreiter und
katrin göring eckardt die sie auch
gerade genannt haben die leer
ausgegangen sind bei der verteilung
jetzt in den letzten tagen relativ
deutlich man sieht denen noch an die
sind damit nicht zufrieden
weil es wie wollen sie das als
parteichef heilen wie und dafür sorgen
dass sich das jetzt nicht durch die
nächsten jahre durchzieht ich möchte bei
allem respekt darauf hinweisen dass das
widersprüchlich ist was sie sagen weil
sie auf der einen seite sagen das gibt
ein flügel auseinandersetzung auf der
anderen seite ja zwei prominente
personen benennen die aus beiden flügel
kommen die nicht gezogen haben am ende
dass die verletzt und enttäuscht
ja die haben ja auch der zärtlich
gezogen weil es dann eben auch um
proporz gegen ihrer ansicht nach ja aber
am ende des tages ist es ja nicht so
dass die reinen gewonnen die anderen
verloren haben und
das ist der geist wir werden uns
unterhaken müssen wir werden sehr viel
kommunizieren müssen und alle hier
anwesenden sind profis und wir sind hier
quasi in der champions league der
politik in deutschland auf dieser flug
ebene bundesregierung dann auch noch und
wir werden uns unterhaken viel reden
miteinander und zusammen erfolgreich
sein
sagt auch mit nouripour bündnis 90 die
grünen der nouripour nicht dass sie
jetzt noch ihre stimmabgabe verpassen
ich bedanke mich
und damit zurück zu dir classic haben ja
und wir bedanken uns bei dir nicole für
das gespräch mit omid nouripour den
nikolaus gradl erstmal in die zange
genommen hat wir haben eva schulz die
dabei uns und eva ich würde gerne dich
bitten noch ein paar fragen aus dem chat
zu beantworten mork vom ork hat eine
frage zum ablauf der wahl er möchte
wissen was passiert wenn scholz die
mehrheit nicht erreicht sind enthaltung
möglich
und gestand das musst du das kannst du
besser beantworten ich
bin halt nicht vorbereitet aber nichts
mit den vorläufen dieser wahl und dann
prozentig vertraut ok dann dann
schließen jetzt den schulterschluss und
machen das einfach zusammen es ist würde
ich sagen wahnsinnig unwahrscheinlich
dass scholz die mehrheit nicht erreicht
und selbstverständlich das hat
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas auch
eben eingangs gesagt sind enthaltungen
möglich eine zweite frage wäre was
passiert wenn er verliert die würden wir
sagen die hätten wir jetzt damit
vielleicht auch schon beantwortet dass
das wahrscheinlich einfach nicht
besonders wahrscheinlich ist wir haben
noch einen kommentar einen inhaltlichen
das wichtigste thema ist definitiv erst
mal die korona pandemie danach der
klimawandel wir kämpfen hier ums
überleben
wie würdest du so ein statement
einschätzen
na ja das ist natürlich aus jeglicher
wählerin sich immer ganz unterschiedlich
ich bin zb auch überrascht dass das
thema club zwischen arm und reich in
deutschland sie wird ja immer größer im
koalitionsvertrag eigentlich eine
nachgeordnete rolle spielt beim hartz 4
wurden die regelsätze nicht erhöht diese
angestrebten steuerhöhe für reiche
deutsche die grüne und spd verfolgt hat
befinden sich auch nicht mehr drin und
ich glaube das ist vielen leuten auch
besonders wichtig nicht desto trotz hat
man finde ich in diesem wahlkampf
gesehen das klima als der ernst der lage
begriffen wurde und auch noch nie eine
so prominente und wichtigere rolle
gespielt hat und das trotz der kooi wie
deswegen bin ich dann freut sich sich
hoffnungsvoll und auch gespannt wie
diese drei koalitionäre dass in den
kommenden vier jahren miteinander aus
und verhandeln werden wenn sie dann ins
machen kommen
das thema soziale gerechtigkeit war ein
thema das der spd ganz ganz weit oben
auf der agenda hatte wie hast du da olaf
scholz in seinem podcast erlebt
na ja wie gesagt das ist das thema das
er auch immer mit diesem schlagwort
respekt ganz nach vorne gestellt hat er
hat sich überall plakate für diesen
mindestlohn eingesetzt der jetzt auch
ausgehandelt wurde der wird einmalig
rapide erhöht auf 12 euro und damit
werden sehr sehr viele menschen besser
verdienen er sprach immer von 10
millionen
gleichzeitig wurde bei den
besserverdienenden deutschen jetzt
meiner wahrnehmung nach gar nicht
angesetzt und ich finde man hätte an
beiden richtungen was machen können um
ebendiese klub von der ich gerade sprach
zu schließen ich denke mal das ist
einfach auch die fdp zurückzuführen dass
die das nicht mit hat mit sicherheit
machen lassen und dazu schreibt
toastbrot auf youtube ich wünsche mir
mehr soziale gerechtigkeit unterstützung
für familien und erneuerbare energien
daher vielleicht noch einen stichwort zu
dem thema unterstützung für familien was
es da zu erwarten was wird da kommen
das ist der eine gewinnt in die spd
verzeichnen kann im sinne oder wenn es
um hartz iv hier geht da wollen sie ja
oder das wird ja eh umbenannt und sie
wollen die kindergrundsicherung
einführen da werden also verschiedene
maßnahmen die bisher schon gab für
familien mit kindern zusammengefasst
alles soll vereinfacht werden und auch
noch zugänglicher der hintergedanke ist
so kinder aus der armut zu holen und das
ist auf jeden fall was sehr positives da
wird natürlich abzuwarten wie schnell
gelingt jetzt die umsetzung davon und
welchen effekt hat dann auch wie viele
menschen in deutschland und
eva eine letzte frage noch an dich
wirst du jetzt auch die künftige
regierung demnächst in einem podcast
haben oder teile der regierung wie geht
es weiter bei dir
also wir beobachten das natürlich bei
deutschland 3.000 auf instagram da es ja
immer der slogan politik nicht da wo sie
gemacht wird sondern da wo sie ankommen
und da will ich jetzt gespannt wie
schnell das geht dass wir eben mit den
leuten sprechen werden die von der
politik betroffen sind die diese neue
koalition macht und im podcast nachdem
ich jetzt diese spitzenpolitiker im
wahlkampfmodus hatte bin ich eher wieder
darauf gespannt wie jüngere
politikerinnen und politiker vielleicht
die die als allererste legislaturperiode
jetzt erleben weil einzuladen und zu
gucken wie die das ist ja auch einer der
jüngsten bundestage bisher wie die dass
in den nächsten vier jahren prägen
werden da freue ich mich drauf und bin
selber gespannt
und da gibt es ja einige davon
erfreulicherweise im bundestag neue
damit wollen wir das beenden liebe eva
schulz wir lassen dich gerne
weiterziehen bedanken uns ganz herzlich
für deine informationen und deine
eindrücke und schilder schilderungen und
freuen uns wenn du dann demnächst mal
wieder bei zdf heute live zu gast bist
danke schön tschüss
liebe userinnen und user wir begleiten
heute morgen die wahl von olaf scholz
zum neuen bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland wir werden
noch einige gesprächspartner innen haben
und wenn sie eine frage oder einen
kommentar loswerden wollen gerne weiter
in die kommentarspalten posten oder ihre
frage an die unten eingeblendete
e-mail-adresse schicken
werden so viel wie möglich davon
beantworten nicole diekmann aus dem
zdf-hauptstadtstudio in berlin steht für
uns seit heute morgen im bundestag
nicolas uns vielleicht mal ein bisschen
über die neue regierung sprechen also
das war ja direkt nach der wahl so dass
sich erstmal fdp und grüne zusammen
getan hatten da gab es dieses tolles
elfi und dann hatte man während der
koalitionsverhandlungen irgendwann mal
so er den eindruck dass fdp und spd sich
zusammentun und die grünen vielleicht so
ein bisschen außen vor sind und mehr wie
das so ist in so dreiecks dreyer
verhältnissen das ist nicht immer ganz
einfach
erwartest du das auch für die nächsten
vier jahre
naja man muss dazu sagen das was du
gerade ja aufgezählt hat das war so
ungefähr alles was man aus den
sondierungs und koalitionsgespräche
mitbekommen hat wir waren da als
journalistinnen und journalisten am
rande des nervenzusammenbruchs weil so
gut wie nichts nach außen drang es war
wahnsinnig diskret und auch sehr
diszipliniert das ging alles sehr sehr
schnell also ich erinnere mich wir saßen
im hauptstadtstudio mit ein paar leuten
zusammen als der terminplan vorgestellt
wurde und die nikolaus woche als der
termin genannt in dem dann zu dem dann
olaf scholz zum kanzler gewählt werden
sollte und wir konnten es gar nicht
fassen und waren kurz alfa wetten
abzuschließen ob es tatsächlich auch
gelingt wie wir heute sehen gelingt es
wohl
das wird sicherlich nicht so bleiben
dass so wenig nach außen dringend aber
es ist im moment wahnsinnig schwierig zu
sagen wer da mit dem besser kann es gibt
auch mit nouripour stand ja gerade bei
mir von den grünen und hat das auch
schon gesagt es gibt themen da sind
grüne und spd näher beieinander
es gibt themen da sind grüne und fdp
näher beieinander die ja zum beispiel
bei den jungen wählerinnen und wähler
abgesahnt haben und es gibt dann auch
noch die andere konstellation also das
ist eine ampel auf bundesebene das muss
man sich auch noch mal vor augen führen
ihrer ersten art das hat es noch nie
gegeben im bund das heißt das kommt noch
zu diesen unwägbarkeiten in diesem
verrückten zeiten stichwort corona zum
beispiel aber auch schauen wir auf die
letzten jahre zurück vielen anderen
krisen die kaum jemand hat kommen sehen
also eine prognose finde ich da heute
sehr gewagt und dann wollen wir
vielleicht noch mal auf den am
parteiinternen frieden schauen kevin
kühnert der designierte generalsekretär
der ja dann auch noch gleich bei dir
sein wird er hat ja schon angekündigt
dass er sich nicht unbedingt sklavisch
so hat er das gesagt an den
koalitionsvertrag gebunden fühlt muss
olaf scholz dann gegebenenfalls auch mit
gegenwind aus seiner eigenen partei
rechnen
das wird ganz interessant die personalie
kevin kühnert ist ja total spannend
kevin kühnert hat vor zwei jahren noch
versucht olaf scholz als
parteivorsitzenden zu verhindern der spd
nun soll er am wochenende zum
generalsekretär gewählt werden wenn das
alles glatt läuft dann ist kühnert der
schweiz mal verhindern wollte demnächst
sehr stark damit beschäftigt die
wiederwahl von scholz als kanzler zu
organisieren kühnert ist anders als der
noch generalsekretär lars klingbeil
niemand der jetzt vor allem
charakterisiert ist oder wird durch
wahnsinnige anpassungsfähigkeit durch
unglaubliche freundlichkeit und sehr
große kompromissbereitschaft kevin kühn
hat ist er abteilung attacke jemand für
klare kante deswegen wird das
tatsächlich interessant wie er sich in
die parteidisziplin weiter einfügt
allerdings ist kevin kühnert ja auch
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender
da wurde er schon ein bisschen ruhiger
innerhalb der partei da wurden die
streitereien weniger seit dieser wahl
und angesprochen auf die frage was denn
das bedeutet man müsse sich nicht an
sklavisch an den koalitionsvertrag
halten hat er das auch relativiert und
gesagt na ja es gibt dinge die stehen in
so einem koalitionsvertrag nicht drin
mit denen kann man vorher nicht rechnen
das muss man immer wieder alles
aushandeln und außerdem ist ja auch
nicht alles komplett schon festgezurrt
in diesem koalitionsvertrag also wir
können damit rechnen dass kevin kühnert
sich mit seinen ecken und kanten
einbringen wird aber ich glaube nicht
dass er als querulant in der eigenen
partei auftreten und die
regierungsarbeit torpedieren wird kevin
kühnert ist ein ganz spannendes thema
und ich bin auch wirklich gespannt auf
das gespräch das team später mit ihm
führen wirst jetzt ist es ja so er ja
wir haben jetzt gleich annika rittmann
von pfennigstorf user freuen wir uns
aber noch einen beitrag anschauen denn
jede der drei regierungsparteien hat im
wahlkampf ja verschiedene schwerpunkte
gehabt bei den grünen war das ganz klar
der kampf den klimawandel und was jetzt
davon tatsächlich im koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben wurde das hat pablo
solón iphone zusammengefasst
deutschland bekommt eine klima regierung
zumindest ist das ihr selbst gestellte
anspruch doch wie viel klimaschutz
steckt wirklich in der ampel zwar nennen
die drei parteien ambitionierte vorgaben
bleiben aber bei der genauen umsetzung
im wagen so plant die ampel den
kohleausstieg bis 2030 allerdings mit
dem zusatz idealerweise 80 prozent des
stroms soll dann aus erneuerbaren
energien kommen erreicht werden soll das
nicht per gesetz der markt soll es
regeln durch einen mindestpreis auf co2
von 60 euro pro tonne welche die
energieunternehmen zahlen müssen
allerdings von einer allgemeinen
anhebung des co2 preises wie es die
grünen im wahlkampf noch versprochen
hatten ist im koalitionsvertrag nicht
mehr die rede dieses geld fehlt dann
allerdings genau wie die eeg-umlage die
soll abgeschafft werden
unverbindlich sind im koalitionsvertrag
die angaben zum geplanten
sozialausgleich bei einem möglichen
höheren co2 preis dem sogenannten klima
geld ambitioniert ist das ziel bei der
elektromobilität 15 millionen
vollelektrische pkw soll es bis 2030
geben doch ansonsten weiß der
koalitionsvertrag beim thema verkehr
viele lehrstellen auf woher das geld für
den klimaschutz kommen soll vor allem
das bleibt für das potsdamer institut
für klimafolgenforschung
unbeantwortet die experten drücken ist
so aus die finanzierung des
klimaschutzes ist die größte black box
der ampel koalition
und jetzt begrüße ich annika rittmann
klimaschutz aktivisten und sprecherin
von friday future hamburg frau widmann
wir haben es ja gerade gesehen wie groß
ist für sie der gap zwischen dem was
versprochen wurde und dem was jetzt
kommt
kann sie noch nicht
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob annika
rittmann uns im moment hören kann
vielleicht kann ich mal einen tipp aus
der regie bekommen also offensichtlich
wird sie uns nicht
okay dann hoffen wir dass das gleich
klappt mit annika riedmann und ich bin
wie immer so froh dass du einfach das
ist und weiter mit und sprechen kannst
solange die kolleginnen und kollegen
ergeben dass du ein problem zu klären
wir schauen mal was is a marcel auf
youtube eine frage warum haben die
grünen nicht das verkehrsministerium
übernommen und ist der fdp überlassen
ja so ist das in koalitionsverhandlungen
da wird gedealt da wird gehandelt und
das verkehrsministerium war dann
anscheinend der preis den die grünen
zahlen mussten für andere punkte die sie
im koalitionsvertrag ausgehandelt haben
wir wissen ja auch es war ja überhaupt
kein geheimnis er das auf den
kommuniziert dass robert habeck von den
grünen sehr sehr gerne finanzminister
werden wollte wird er nicht wird jetzt
fdp chef christian lindner dafür bekommt
robert habeck ein superministerium mit
zuständigkeit für klimaschutz und
wirtschaft auch da gab es einen handel
das ist völlig normal in der politik
und ich glaube eine doku mit robert
habeck der ja auch erklärt hat wie
teilweise solche verhandlungen
ablaufen der ja irgendwie auch erzählt
hat wenn dann mal irgendeine kleinigkeit
nach draußen gedrungen ist dann war das
für die anderen parteien gleich
irgendwie einen grund zu sagen okay ihr
habt das durchgesteckt dafür haben wir
jetzt bei dem und dem punkt bessere
verhandlungsposition macht es
tatsächlich so
man muss ich habe das ja eben auch schon
gesagt noch mal gucken wie diszipliniert
und wie unglaublich verschwiegen dann
doch diese sondierungs und
koalitionsverhandlungen abgelaufen sind
also da haben wir uns hier wirklich
die haare gerauft am schreibtisch im
hauptstadtstudio und sicherlich nur bei
uns nicht nur bei uns im
hauptstadtstudio es dann kaum was nach
außen und das war auch eine folge des
trauma so kann man das nennen von 2017
als ja über jamaika verhandelt wurde und
wahnsinnig viel nach außen drang und am
ende jamaika ja auch platzte was auch
damit zu tun hatte dass überhaupt keine
vertrauensbasis entstehen konnte
zwischen union grünen und fdp wieder
gemeinsam am tisch saßen und hinzu kommt
auch noch wir erleben ja seit der korona
pandemie eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nach der
anderen immer wieder haben sich
kanzleramt und die länderchefs
zusammengeschaltet und beraten über
maßnahmen in der pandemie wie man corona
am besten eindämmen können und da konnte
man verfolgen dass die springer medien
allen voran die bild quasi ticker
meldungen veröffentlichte die sie ganz
offensichtlich per sms aus diesen
eigentlicher vertraulichen runden
erhalten hatte und das ist doch auch
wirklich viel kritik gestoßen auch
mittlerweile in der cdu das ist ganz
interessant da wird ja gerade um den
parteivorsitz gekämpft und vergangene
woche sagte friedrich merz bei einem
townhall meeting der ja kandidiert als
parteichef er würde dafür sorgen sollte
er der cdu demnächst vorsitzen das in
den vorstands- und präsidiumssitzung die
handys vorher abgegeben werden also das
heißt
der unwille ist mittlerweile sehr sehr
groß dass diese durchstechereien so
weitergehen und das war eben jetzt auch
in den koalitionsverhandlungen so und
man hat sich tatsächlich fast sklavisch
daran gehalten
nicole vielen dank wieder für den moment
wurde gerade gesagt dass ich es jetzt
noch mal versuchen kann mit annika
rittmann
da ist sie annika können sie mich jetzt
höre ja
okay sie kann uns hören aber wir können
sie leider noch nicht hören
wir haben sie wunderbar anka riedmann
klimaschutz aktivistin und sprecherin
von friday is for future hamburg einen
schönen guten tag schön dass sie sich an
diesem morgen auch zeit für uns genommen
haben
meine frage war eben wenn sie sich
anschauen was jetzt in sachen
klimaschutz im koalitionsvertrag
drinsteht wie groß ist da der gap für
sie zwischen dem was versprochen wurde
und dem was jetzt kommen soll
na ja versprochen wurde im wahlkampf von
allen drei parteien die einhaltung wir
endlich mal fünf grad grenze und das
kann dieser koalitionsvertrag einfach
nicht leisten mit den großen lücken was
den gas aufstieg angeht was gerade auch
den verkehr zeit blieb und was zum
beispiel auch im pm das budget also
keine transparenz angeht und damit
schaffen uns die ampel verteidigen nicht
ihre wahlversprechen einzuhalten und das
ist ja einfach schauen dass man
festhalten muss und was ein skandal ist
in diesem wahlkampf den wir gesehen und
geführt haben
ich konnte ihre antwort jetzt leider
nicht ganz hören
deshalb hoffe ich dass ich jetzt
irgendwie was doppelt frage aber ihre
bewegungen hatte ja eckpunkte vorgelegt
wo ganz klar formuliert war was
passieren muss um eben doch noch auf
diesen 1,5 grad zu kommen wo sehen sie
ihre forderungen denn am wenigsten
erfüllt
das co2 budget steht gar nicht im
koalitionsvertrag das heißt es wurde das
letzte klimaziele regierung nicht
angerufen und die neue regierung hat
aber auch nicht klar gesagt nicht so
zweig noch imitieren wirken wie
klimaneutral werden und das ist ein
riesenproblem weil man ohne die
funktionieren ziele natürlich auch nicht
mit den maßnahmen dahin kommen dass
gerade ganz einzuhalten anders als
robert habeck das irgendwie in der
vergangenheit jetzt gesagt
sie hatten ihre forderung ja klar
formuliert das habe ich gerade gesagt
feines for future darf wirklich versucht
da druck zu machen luisa neubau hatte
gesagt die zeit der ausreden ist vorbei
und wem geben sie jetzt in der neuen
regierung konkret die schuld daran dass
diese maßnahmen aus ihrer sicht nicht
weit genug gehen
diese krise ist viel zu groß um
eine kopie ministerin oder eine partei
die schuld dafür zu geben dass es nicht
im koalitionsvertrag steht alle parteien
haben eben mit dem wahlversprechen die
verantwortung die maßnahmen koalition zu
schreiben und dann in der regierungszeit
jetzt gerade in den ersten 100 tagen
auch umzusetzen das heißt da stellen wir
den klaren anspruch dass alle parteien
da ihre ambitionen überarbeiten einige
eben mehr als andere
wir haben eine frage aus dem chat wieso
spielt die verkehrswende im
koalitionsvertrag eigentlich fast gar
keine rolle eine verkehrswende kann es
keine wende in der klimakrise geben
würden sie das so unterschreiben
was ist die verhandlung darüber gedacht
haben ein wenig sagen klar ist aber dass
der verkehrsbereich unglaublich offen
gehalten ist und das kann nicht sein in
einem land in geben der verkehrsrechner
mit einer der größten co2 emittenten ist
und da ist ein wenn wir auf jeden fall
weiter auf der straße unglaublichen
druck machen damit da dann also
verkehrsministerium und aus den anderen
ministerium über diesen kollidiert
hinaus eine verkehrspolitik gemacht wird
zu einer gerechten verkehrswende für die
alle leute mitnimmt weil auch das
leistet irgendwer vergesst hier noch
nicht
welche erwartungen haben sie jetzt
konkret weil positiv formuliert an
robert robert habeck den neuen
klimaminister
ich habe ja schon gesagt ich glaube man
darf die verantwortung nicht nur auf
robert habeck abschieben wobei er
natürlich in seinem ministerium eine
unglaubliche verantwortung hat und da es
auf jeden fall die
unsere anforderungen dass er jetzt
niemals an dem koalitionsvertrag spielt
konsequent angehen die wir in dem
ministerium liegen und gerade innerhalb
der ersten 100 tage eben druck macht das
vernünftige maßnahme umgesetzt werden
und da auch die an der ministerin
natürlich mitnehmen
und wenn wir mal das thema finanzierung
angehen für wie glaubwürdig halten sie
denn diese im koalitionsvertrag
versprochenen klimaschutzmaßnahmen wo ja
eigentlich noch nicht mal so wirklich
klar ist wie das alles finanziert werden
oder einen klaren finanzierungsplan
scheidenden maß an gegen
koalitionsvertrag schäden de facto
wertlos und solange die ampelkoalition
uns nicht sagen kann wie das finanziert
sind die erwartungen eben das am ende
diese maßnahme umgesetzt werden und wir
eben den kurs der letzten regierung gar
nicht so massig versteigert werden das
heißt da es eben die klare forderung
jetzt ein finanzierungsplan vorzulegen
und klar zu sagen wir können das
finanzieren wir werden das finanzieren
und dann wie wasser umzusetzen aber dass
es nicht abzuwarten es jetzt aussieht
und wenn sie mir zum schluss noch den
satz vervollständigen würden eine rot
grün gelbe regierung bedeutet für frei
dsv future
weiter auf die straße zu gehen und druck
zu machen damit diese koalition nicht
nur besser ist als die letzte sondern 15
grad einhält und damit echten gerechten
klimaschutz umsetzen kann in einer
transformation die über ein bisschen
innovation hinausgeht
vielen dank das war klimaschutz
aktivistin annika rittmann von frey des
computer einen schönen tag noch danke
ich im kies
wir schauen jetzt mal auf die uhr es ist
9 uhr 45 das bedeutet die abstimmung
läuft seit gut einer dreiviertelstunde
es sind ja über 700
abgeordnete die abstimmen müssen ganz
genau sind es 7 136 wir haben von omid
nouripour gelernt man braucht so ein
blaues kärtchen damit man abstimmen kann
und wenn das ergebnis der
stimmenauszählung da ist dann wird das
voraussichtlich von bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas daneben auch
verkündet danach geht es für olaf scholz
der jetzt noch im bundestag sitzt
erstmal ins schloss bellevue zu
bundespräsident steinmeier dort wird er
dann seine ernennungsurkunde bekommen
und dann muss er wieder zurück in den
bundestag und da wird dann vereidigt
werden und
für die ministerin und minister der
neuen regierung am wetter genau das dann
auch nochmal heute ablaufen im anschluss
die müssen dann auch erstmal noch ins
schloss bellevue und werden nach und
nach im bundestag vereidigt
nicole diekmann aus dem zdf
hauptstadtstudio berlin ist heute morgen
bei uns eben habe sie gesehen jetzt
schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz in den
bundestag
wir werden gleich nochmal über den
politiker olaf scholz sprechen und
vorher hat andreas andreas kienast ja
noch so eine art portrait über ihnen
gemacht schauen wir uns an
auf wenig ist olaf scholz so stolz wie
auf seine führungserfahrung gesammelt
einmal als senator in hamburg
zweimal als erster bürgermeister von
hamburg
ich schwöre es zweimal als
bundesminister ich schwöre ich würde es
für wenig ist olaf scholz so scharf und
so parteiübergreifend kritisiert worden
wie für fehlende führung in den wochen
vor seinem wichtigsten dem kanzler
schwur als die instanzen steigen als die
vierte welle steigt will die noch
kanzlerin handeln aber der bald kanzler
bremst scholz herrscht bereits über die
bundestagsmehrheit und schwankt es wird
die erste bewährungsprobe der ampel es
wird erst entschärft dann korrigiert
dann verschärft eine management krise
des krisenmanagers scholz das ist alles
sehr sehr holprig angelaufen jetzt wird
nachgebessert ja jetzt werden dinge
umgesetzt die wir bereits vor einigen
wochen gefordert haben wir hätten uns
gefreut wenn olaf scholz früher und
energischer die initiative übernommen
hätte ich habe eine etwas andere lesart
von dem was da passiert ist das ist ja
wir erinnern dass alle nie ganz einfach
mit 16 ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidenten die sehr
unterschiedliches infektionsgeschehen
haben aber am ende ist da eine gute
lösung rausgekommen
als ersten schritt der neuen regierung
richtet scholz einen krisenstab ein der
vor allem die lieferung und verteilung
von impfstoff stärken soll chef wird
general carsten bräuer den scholz
persönlich kennt und schätzt für die
alte regierung ein déjà vu als im
februar die kritik an der schleppenden
impfkampagne eskaliert drängt scholz
darauf eine task force einzurichten die
vor allem die lieferung und produktion
von impfstoff stärken soll chef wird der
spitzenbeamte christoph krupp den scholz
persönlich kennt und schätzt nun
arbeiten zwei impfstoff stäbe parallel
was mich jetzt wundert ist dass jetzt
alles neu werden muss neue beauftragte
neue krisenstäbe weil es ja so war das
olaf scholz mit dabei waren er schleicht
sich so aus der alten regierung raus er
tut so als wenn er mit der alten
regierung gar nichts zu tun gehabt hat
was scholz am besten kann ist führung
sagt scholz der die kanzlerschaft in
einer tiefen krise übernimmt aber nicht
in seiner ersten die steueraffäre um ex
durchleuchtet in hamburg ein
untersuchungsausschuss also olaf scholz
bleibt einer einmal entwickelten linie
treu und diese stärke nicht zu wackeln
ist aber gleichzeitig auch seine größte
schwäche denn wenn die zeit es erfordert
findet er da ganz schwer heraus die
ausschreitungen beim g20-gipfel hat ein
sonderausschuss untersucht die
verantwortung immer genau dann wenn es
drauf ankommt erfolgen ist der who
präsent aber sofort weg wenn es
schwierig wird im skandal um wirecard
hat ein
bundestags-untersuchungsausschuss
ermittelt ich habe manndeckung gemacht
bei olaf scholz und er ist ein spieler
der sich tot stellt über 90 minuten und
dann lässt er sich in der 93 ein
wechseln und jubelt beim tor wolfgang
schmidt ist der engste vertraute und der
lauteste verteidiger des nächsten
kanzlers olaf scholz tten politiker der
sehr klar ist und konsequenzen zieht und
wenn etwas in den eigenen
verantwortungsbereich passiert was nicht
gut läuft dann geht es darum die fehler
zu erkennen sie abzustellen konsequenzen
zu ziehen
und wenn nötig wie zb beim g20-gipfel in
hamburg wo echte fehler passiert sind
sich dann auch zu entschuldigen auch
dass scholz die namen seiner
regierungsmannschaft so spät wie möglich
nennt ist prinzip egal wie sehr er
gedrängt wird der rekord 2011 dauert bis
eine woche nach seiner vereidigung
nicole diekmann heute im bundestag
ansonsten im zdf hauptstadtstudio berlin
nicole kantholz krise auch als kanzler
das ist eine gute frage und er wird
sofort die gelegenheit haben das zu
beweisen oder beziehungsweise zu zeigen
ob er das tatsächlich kann denn wir
haben ja gerade im stück von meinem
kollegen an die kinder ist auch schon
gehört er übernimmt das amt des
regierungschefs in einer dramatischen
krise in der vierten welle von der wir
noch gar nicht wissen ob sie überhaupt
schon ihren höhepunkt erreicht hat der
korona pandemie hier in deutschland die
zahlen sind sehr hoch intensivmediziner
und intensiv medizinerinnen warnen seit
wochen die intensivstation sind voll wir
haben bilder gesehen in den letzten ein
zwei wochen dramatische bilder von
patientinnen und patienten die verlegt
werden müssen intensivpatienten
schwerkranke menschen die in flugzeuge
verladen werden weil man dort wo sie
ursprünglich lagen nicht mehr so für sie
sorgen kann wie man das eigentlich
müsste und möchte die korona pandemie
spielt in dieses szenario natürlich
total mit rein das heißt olaf scholz
wird diese 100 tage schonfrist jemand ja
eigentlich einer neuen regierung
traditionell einräumt die werden er und
sein kabinett überhaupt nicht haben es
geht gleich los beziehungsweise es ist
ja schon losgegangen bevor man überhaupt
die amtsgeschäfte übernimmt
infektionsschutzgesetz
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
damit saß zwar noch angela merkel als
geschäftsführende kanzlerin am tisch
aber natürlich auch der kanzler in spe
olaf scholz der wie gesagt jetzt direkt
in eine fette krise hinein geht die er
möglichst gut managen muss
und da muss man ja auch dazu sagen dass
der anfang mit dem feststellen der des
endes der epidemischen notlage ja auch
nicht so unbedingt glücklich ankam
ja da gibt es zwei lesarten es gibt die
lesart der ampel die das ja beschlossen
hat die sagt natürlich verteidigend es
war die richtige entscheidung wir haben
damit das instrumentarium den
instrumentenkasten
verfeinert präzisiert mit dessen hilfe
jetzt die länder gegen die pandemie
vorgehen können auf der anderen seite
ist aber vor allem die cdu die union die
sagt das ist es völlig falsche signal in
der größten krise in der schwersten
fälle die wir hier in deutschland seit
ausbruch der pandemie erleben die
pandemische lage von nationaler
tragweite zu beenden denn das signal ist
es ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so
schlimm zur wahrheit gehört der noch
geschäftsführende
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn ist
cdu politiker und von ihm kam
ursprünglich dieser vorschlag mal den
hat er später revidiert aber der
vorschlag war im raum genauso wie auch
die fdp vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit
ein freedom day in aussicht gestellt
hatte und wie wir sehen von dem sind wir
nun im moment wirklich weit entfernt
absolut und wenn man sich überlegt wie
du sagst dass die fdp vor ein paar
wochen diesen freedom day gerne gehabt
hätte und christian lindner so weit geht
dass er sagt ist mittlerweile zumindest
nachdenklich was eine allgemeine
impfpflicht angeht dann hat man ja auch
schon den eindruck dass die parteien
sich eben auf die aktuelle situation
einstellen und möglicherweise da auch
eine eine transformation durch machen
also sie haben ganz offensichtlich den
ernst der lage erkannt sie haben auch
die öffentliche kritik gehört die war
auch nicht zu überhören die war
ohrenbetäubend zum schluss da ging es
zum einen darum dass man jetzt mal
schneller handeln muss morgen ist der
neunte dezember ursprünglich sollte
morgen die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattfinden die sich mit den drängenden
fragen in dieser partie auseinandersetzt
die findet zwar statt aber es gab auch
schon vergangene woche eine und zwei
tage zuvor gab es auch schon eine
sitzung das hat man vorgezogen weil man
eben gemerkt hat erstens es geht nicht
anders und zweitens die öffentlichkeit
macht so eindruck das verständnis ist
überhaupt nicht mehr da du hast es
gerade schon gesagt das thema
impfpflicht gestern war hier in erster
lesung eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in einer
sondersitzung im bundestag soll am
freitag nach zweiter und dritter lesung
und hier dann auch in einer
sondersitzung des bundesrates
verabschiedet werden das zeigt auch noch
mal die dramatik und die dringlichkeit
in dieser änderungs vorlage geht es um
eine einrichtung bezogene künftig zum
beispiel für krankenhäuser für
pflegeeinrichtungen altenheime und so
weiter es wird aber jetzt längst über
eine allgemeine impfpflicht also für
alle gesprochen und da hatte die fdp in
der ampelkoalition
den weitesten weg zurückzulegen
interessanterweise hat fdp chef lindner
am sonntagabend bei uns im zdf im heute
journal aber darauf hingewiesen dass 77
prozent
der fairness halber muss man sagen das
sind zahlen die die ard kolleginnen und
kollegen erhoben haben 77 prozent der
fdp wähler sprechen sich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht aus da kommt man
als partei dann ja quasi gar nicht mehr
drumherum
das ist ein klares votum das ist eine
ganz klare aussage der wählerinnen und
wähler
jetzt hat man schon von seiten der fdp
die losung ausgegeben wenn es zur
abstimmung im bundestag kommt ist der
sogenannte fraktionszwang aufgehoben
dann kann man frei dafür oder dagegen
stimmen aber ja die zeichen der zeit sie
scheinen jetzt erkannt worden zu sein
so dann lass uns noch mal ein paar
fragen aus dem chat klären bitte
am anfang der sendung schon mal darüber
gesprochen aber der eine oder die andere
ist jetzt in den letzten jahren über
eine stunde sind wir schon noch dazu
gekommen daher die frage von horst auf
youtube beziehungsweise er stellt fest
gut dass wir nicht mehr in einer
pandemie sind man stelle sich vor die
menschen würden abstand voneinander
halten das ist jetzt ein bisschen
zynisch gemeint und da spielt er darauf
an dass man wenn man die bilder aus dem
bundestag aus dem plenarsaal sieht dann
doch diese menschen gruppen sieht die
aber ja auch maske tragen könntest du
nochmal die korona regeln im bundestag
erklären
naja hier wird wir werden alle
abgeordneten auch alle besucher im
bundestag gefragt genesen oder getestet
das ist hier ganz klar es herrscht auch
auf den gängen hier masken pflicht also
von daher ja das stimmt man sieht hier
bilder
ohne abstand aber es ist natürlich
vorher intensiv geprüft worden
gut dann noch eine weitere frage
es gab einige kommentare vor hin zum
wirecard wirecard skandal und da würde
ich gerne noch mal deine einschätzung
hören was denkst du an die sehr wird
dieser wirecard skandal auch an einem
kanzler scholz haften bleiben
naja diese wirecard skandal hat ja auch
den wahlkampf begleitet aus sicht von
olaf scholz und der spd überschattet das
hat olaf scholz wie wir heute sehen ja
höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht daran gehindert zum kanzler
gewählt zu werden beziehungsweise es hat
die leute nicht daran gehindert ihnen
dann auch zu wählen olaf scholz heißt
einmal deshalb scholzomat weil er
nicht bekannt ist für gefühlsausbrüche
für große emotionalität aber er ist auch
ein meister des an sich abperlen lassen
der hat da so eine teflon taktik also
bisher
ist da wenig auf ihn tatsächlich
zurückgefallen so dass es große
auswirkungen gehabt hätte die frage ist
warum sollte das jetzt in seiner
kanzlerschaft anders sein wenn erst
bisher bis hierhin geschafft hat
mika schreibt den koalitionsvertrag kann
man auch in einem satz zusammenfassen
doppelpunkt anführungsstriche wir sind
angetreten um die reichen noch reicher
zu machen und die armen noch ärmer zu
machen
liest du dass zwischen den zeilen in dem
koalitionsvertrag
also sicherlich ist nicht alles super in
diesem koalitionsvertrag aber
also stichwort mindestlohn von 12 euro
spricht dagegen eine
kindergrundsicherung
spricht dagegen
die hartz-iv-reform hat es soll ja nicht
mehr hartz 4 heißen auch da soll es
änderungen geben da gibt es viel kritik
auch schon an den geplanten änderungen
das geht vielen nicht weit genug
vielleicht spielt die userinnen darauf
an dass die von der spd während des
wahlkampfs in aussicht gestellten
steuererleichterungen für die mitte für
die finanzielle mitte der gesellschaft
die sind die kommen nicht also es waren
keine steuererhöhungen für die reichen
sondern es sollten steuererleichterungen
geben für die drunter die sind nicht
gekommen aber so pauschal kann man das
so nicht verdammen was in diesem
koalitionsvertrag steht
nicole vielen dank für den moment wir
werden später noch weiter sprechen mich
schon mal kurz auf die uhr jetzt ist es
10 uhr seit 9 uhr ist die sitzung im
bundestag eröffnet die wahl des neuen
bundeskanzlers läuft die abgeordneten
werden namentlich aufgerufen
und müssen dann in geheimer wahl
abstimmen
das sind
736 abgeordnete und deshalb können wir
davon ausgehen dass das auch einen
moment dauert meine kollegin nicole
diekmann mit der ich gleich gesprochen
habe wird dann auch gleich noch jetzt
habe ich meinen oben verloren sekunde
dass kirche auch wieder was
wird dann auch gleich noch den
designierten spd generalsekretär kevin
kühnert vom mikro haben und wir kommen
nochmal einmal kurz auf das thema corona
management zurück denn die neue
regierung nimmt ihre arbeit ja inmitten
der vierten welle auf und dazu schauen
wir uns daniel pontzen and politics an
bei einem sind sich wahrscheinlich alle
einig einen guten zeitpunkt für eine
pandemie gibt es nicht aber einen
besonders schlechten superwahljahr
nämlich denn da gibt es besonders die
parteitaktik und wenn wir eines gelernt
haben in den letzten anderthalb jahren
dann virus plus parteitaktik gleich hier
geht es nicht mehr um parteitaktik
sondern ein traum den schutz der
menschen ganz genau wie das den staat
manche sagen viel staat von olaf scholz
neue regierung geprägt hat das zeichnen
wir nach in diesem video teil 1 teil 2
ein ausblick wird jetzt alles besser
nach den jüngsten beschlüssen bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und der
dort ja zelebrierten geschlossenheit die
man danach gezeigt als kleiner spoiler
von einer die es wissen muss nach der
wahl ist vor der wahl merkel geht ampel
kommt gruner
im wahlkampf im sommer war corona kein
großes thema weil fallzahlen niedrig
viele leute waren genervt von dem thema
war kein gewinnerthema deswegen blieben
dann aber viele debatten geführt jetzt
hektisch nachgeholt werden zum beispiel
3g am arbeitsplatz zum beispiel locker
und verunglimpfte zum beispiel
impfpflicht in altenheim ja das wird
jetzt debattiert wo die vierte welle
durch viele altenheime schon durch
gerollt ist thema wird kroner dann so
richtig erst wieder nach der wahl und da
kam das parteitaktische dann so richtig
mit voller wucht ins spiel denn die
ampel die wollte gleich zu beginn signal
setzen fest steht für uns und das sage
ich auch sehr deutlich schulschließungen
lockt downs und ausgangssperren wird es
jedenfalls mit uns nicht mehr geben wir
werden jetzt einen überschaubaren
katalog wenig eingriffs intensiver
maßnahmen zur verfügung stellen die
ampel funktioniert auch bevor es sie
gibt also die ampel wollte die
sogenannte epidemische notlage von
nationaler tragweite
auslaufen lassen weil diese so genannte
notlage der exekutive also den
regierungen von bund und ländern
besonders weitreichende befugnisse gibt
bei der pandemie bekämpfen die ampel hat
jetzt gesagt das holen wir zurück in die
parlamente bis jetzt prinzipiell auch
keine so doofe idee in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie die wir
haben aber die ampel hatte maximal
bescheidenes timing denn just zu dem
zeitpunkt wo sie die notlage auslaufen
lassen wollte wie es begann sich die
vierte welle aufzutürmen und dann ging's
los
[Musik]
die ampel parteien die wollten partout
an ihrem plan festhalten weil
zurückrudern dass er ja nach fehlstart
aus und da klangen die grünen dann
manchmal wie die fdp auf die das ganze
zurückging
an gerichten wieder gekippt von den
gerichten gekippt mit einer sehr
ähnlichen begründung hatte der da noch
gesundheitsminister jens spahn im grunde
genau dasselbe gefordert nämlich die
notlage auslaufen zu lassen interessant
jetzt die reaktion seiner partei der
union die gab sich nun sehr erzürnt
darüber dass die notlage auslaufen soll
das sei ein falsches signal
beziehungsweise das völlig falsche
signal um nicht zu sagen es wird ein in
jeder hinsicht fatales signal an die
bevölkerung gegeben oder um es
zusammenzufassen war es völlig absurd
wenn er eine epidemie schlage aussuchen
völlig absurd hier geht es ja nicht nur
ein parteitaktik sondern ein von den
schutz der menschen eben und deswegen
gucken wir uns die ganze sache jetzt mal
ein bisschen genauer an das fatale an
dem signal sei so die kritiker zweierlei
zum einen eben die falsche signalwirkung
nach dem motto die prekäre lage ist
vorbei und zweitens dass die besonders
betroffenen länder wie zum beispiel
bayern ja nicht mehr alle instrumente
der pandemie bekämpfung zur verfügung
hätten weil aus diesem berühmten
instrumentenkasten einzelne dieser
instrumente rausgenommen werden und
tatsächlich war es auch so dass hat die
ampel gemacht immerhin kleiner trost es
gab da ein kompromiss die instrumente
die wegfallen die frist dafür die wird
noch mal ein bisschen verlängert von
ende november bis mitte dezember
vorausgesetzt diese instrumente haben
schon gegolten ende november aber davon
wird man ja ausgehen in den besonders
stark betroffenen bundesländern außerdem
bräuchte man sich ja sonst nicht darüber
beklagen dass eben diese instrumente
wegfallen wenn man sie gar nicht
einsetzt gehen wie die einzelnen
instrumente also nochmal durch bleiben
gern beim beispiel bayer dennoch daher
ging es ja zur erinnerung ein traum den
schutz der menschen also gucken wir mal
welche der maßnahmen welche der
instrumente die welt zu fallen drohten
handeln dann schon gegolten ende
november zum stichtag in bayern als die
infektionszahlen daher schon ziemlich
hoch waren
instrument 1 flächendeckende
ausgangssperren gab es die
wie war es denn mit flächendeckenden
schließung von kitas und schulen
die waren jetzt nirgendwo populär die
wollte niemand aber wie war es denn mit
der vorsorglichen flächendeckenden
schließung von gastronomie die ganz
sicher oder
und vom einzelhandel
verbot von gottesdiensten und
versammlungen
von reisen und
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten
jetzt sagt denn verstehe ich den ganzen
protest der unionsländer aber nicht so
richtig wenn wir sagen ist auch nicht so
leicht zu verstehen es sei denn man
versteht diesen move jetzt eben auch als
parteitaktisch motiviert auf der anderen
seite der ampel führte diese logik dann
allerdings auch zu der einen oder
anderen argumentativen verrenkungen den
schultern überlasteten intensivstationen
wird am ende natürlich auch keiner sein
sie können jetzt sehr drastische
maßnahmen ergreifen auch in sachsen auch
in bayern wir sind auf sie zugegangen
haben gesagt solche maßnahmen haben
einen längeren übergang bis über den
dritten advent hinaus dann muss es aber
jetzt auch gemacht werden meine damen
und herren wenn ihr das jetzt so
verstanden habt jetzt würde frau
göring-eckardt dafür werben nach schnell
die maßnahmen einzusetzen die ihre
partei dann mit abschafft dann habt ihr
es fürchte ich richtig verstanden
[Musik]
der text bild schere nennen wir beim
fernsehen wenn das was wir hören nicht
passt zu dem was wir sehen und davon
gibt es eine reihe von beispielen zum
beispiel er hier hendrik wüst neuer
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen nachfolger von armin
laschet der hat damit gedroht das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz der ampel mit
ebendiesem ausgedünnten
instrumentenkasten zu blockieren mit
einem veto im bundesrat weil eben und
falsche signal stichwort falsches signal
genau das hat er gesagt wenige tage
nachdem er das hier in seinem bundesland
noch ziemlich okay fand und weitere acht
tage später stand dann das hier in
seinem bundesland statt fun fact dazu
nicht alles was an dem nachmittag dort
auf der anzeigetafel zu lesen war fand
ich witzig binder von der amnestie 1
klatsche bekommen aber über eine sache
muss ich doch ein bisschen spielen
und da wird sich einer im stadion
vermutlich gedacht haben was machen
diese menschen das war der rückweg
schauen wir nach vorn
gab also jetzt ja wieder so ne mpk
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im
kanzleramt ihr fragt euch jetzt
vielleicht wieso eigentlich genau damit
wollte die ampel doch eigentlich schluss
machen mit diesen exekutiven zirkeln im
kanzleramt mit der sogenannten re
parlamentarisierung offensive doch
wollte sie aber der politische druck
wurde daneben offenbar doch zu groß also
hat man sich wieder getroffen im
kanzleramt und genau dort soll sie jetzt
und ob auch noch neuen krisenstab geben
geleitet von einem general ob unter dem
alles besser wird ob da das
parteitaktische dann keine zentrale
rolle mehr spielen wird langfristig ob
also alle an einem strang ziehen und es
sogar noch in die selbe richtung werden
wir sehen müssen immerhin nach dieser im
bka war der erste eindruck ganz gut
demonstrative geschlossenheit
sie sehen an den beschlüssen dass wir
verstanden haben dass die lage sehr
ernst ist und ich bin froh dass in
dieser schwierigen lage der
schulterschluss funktioniert dass die
parteipolitik in den hintergrund tritt
dass wir schneller boostern und da
glaube ich kommen wir seit gestern
endlich voran und umso wichtiger ist es
dass ich jetzt bund und länder zusammen
getan haben solche geschlossenheit
zwischen cdu und den ampel parteien die
gab es tatsächlich selten oder ich würde
sogar sagen noch nie in der pandemie
bekämpfung die entscheidende frage ist
jetzt allerdings wie nachhaltig ist
diese geschlossenheit diese
ernsthaftigkeit eine sache die dafür
sprechen könnte dass die ampel parteien
also spd grüne und fdp schon gewissen
hebel auf die landesregierung haben weil
in allen landesregierungen mindestens
eine der ampel parteien also die spd die
grünen oder und oder die fdp drin sitzen
in allen 16 bundesländern
bis auf eines weswegen hier in berlin
viele bei den ampel parteien aber auch
bei der cdu davon ausgehend
beziehungsweise befürchten dass es auch
künftig aus bayern bei der pandemie
bekämpfung sehr viele familien
freundlich formuliert gute ratschläge
geben wird und pünktlich zur mpk gab es
auch wieder ein bei der mpk sitzt markus
söder jetzt nicht mehr in der ersten
reihe mit dabei vielleicht auch deshalb
gab es deswegen schon mal vorab via
medien einen vorschlag und zwar hier zur
impfpflicht ab 12 generell wäre es
natürlich gut wenn die impfpflicht
zumindest bei denen bei denen der
impfstoff schon ein produkt ist ab 12
auch stattfinden würde könnte man den
eindruck gewinnen sie hier nicht ganz
unrecht nach der wahl ist vor der wahl
genau deswegen ist die frage wird das
parteitaktische tatsächlich auf dauer
zur seite gedrängt guck mal auf bayern
da ist 2023 landtagswahl und auch wenn
das also noch ein bisschen weg ist kann
man davon ausgehen die csu wird das
mindestens schon im hinterkopf haben
weil deren besondere rolle im
parteienspektrum in deutschland gründet
darauf dass sie in bayern über
jahrzehnte der überragende ergebnisse
hatte und wenn sie da mit 31 prozent
damit wird das natürlich nicht
beizubehalten sei aber nächstes jahr
sind schon vier andere landtagswahlen in
deutschland zunächst im märz im sana
dann im mai in schleswig-holstein und
nordrhein-westfalen und dann im oktober
in niedersachsen spätestens dann werden
wir wissen ob man gelernt hat aus dem
superwahljahr 20 21 oder ob die pandemie
bekämpfung dann nächstes jahr wieder
überlagert wird von parteitaktik
[Musik]
also wird jetzt alles besser unter der
ampel bei der pandemie bekämpfung hängt
maßgeblich von zwei dingen ab erstens
wie entschlossen und frühzeitig die
bundesländer jetzt die maßnahmen
ergreifen die notwendig sind und
zweitens wie lange die disziplin anhält
bei allen beteiligten akteuren aller
parteien lange sie die pandemie
bekämpfung tatsächlich an 1 stellen vor
parteitaktischen erwägungen was glaubt
ihr was eure prognose war das jetzt der
game changer wird die ampel warten oder
bleibt das inoffizielle maskottchen der
deutschen pandemie politik
soweit die sicht von daniel pontzen in
politics auf die aktuelle politik wir
wollen vielleicht noch mal einen blick
in den plenarsaal werfen
ja da sehen wir dass viele stühle gerade
leer sind denn die meisten abgeordneten
sind gerade draußen unterwegs sie werden
aufgerufen
in geheimer wahl abzustimmen ihre stimme
abzugeben für die wahl des
bundeskanzlers des neunten
bundeskanzlers der bundesrepublik
deutschland wir haben gelernt
736 abgeordnete es dauert ein bisschen
nennen wenn dann alle ihre stimme
abgegeben haben dann muss ja auch noch
ausgezählt werden um 9 uhr hat diese zum
begonnen bundestags präsidentin bärbel
bas hat sie eröffnet jetzt haben wir ja
jetzt um 1910
gegen 10 uhr 30 heiß es soll es ein
ergebnis geben in der warten mal ab ob
das dann auch so pünktlich sein wird
danach wird olaf scholz wenn er denn
gewählt ist wovon wir einfach mal
ausgehen werden
ins schloss bellevue fahren zu
bundespräsident steinmeier ja da erhält
er dann seine ernennungsurkunde und dann
geht es wieder schnell zurück in den
bundestag denn da wird er dann in die
verteidigungs formel sprechen für uns im
bundestag ist heute morgen zdf
hauptstadtstudio korrespondentin nicole
diekmann solange wir zeit haben wollen
wir noch ein paar fragen aus dem chat
klären
was mich mal schauen meter
ja genau lasst lass uns über die
spannendste personalie
dieser dieses neuen kabinetts sprechen
über karl lauterbach mike schreibt la
verpachtet härter durchgreifen als
sparen was aber auch angemessen ist
tja was heißt härter durchgreifen also
erstens wird ja karl lauterbach jetzt
nicht der alleinherrscher deutschland
sondern kann lauterbach wird
bundesgesundheitsminister
der ist genauso auf mehrheiten
angewiesen und auf ein kabinett das
seine entscheidung mitträgt wie jeder
andere minister auch das ist das eine
das andere ist
was bedeutet hätte dass das müsste man
dann vielleicht einfach näher definieren
was tatsächlich ja ein
großes argument war in der im vorfeld
der nominierung von karl lauterbach zum
bundesgesundheitsminister der ja viel
öffentlichen zuspruch erfahren hat das
ist seine wie viele sagen fachliche
eignung karl lauterbach ist mediziner
und epidemiologe und
hat sich in den letzten monaten in
talkshows in interviews in o tönen immer
wieder zu wort gemeldet und sehr
dezidiert zu wort gemeldet also das
stimmt ob er härter durchgreifen wird
wie gesagt das ist eine formulierung
über die kann man diskutieren aber
er gilt als sehr profiliert und auf ihm
ruhen sehr sehr viele hoffnungen ich
glaube das kann man zu 100 prozent
unterstreichen genau die erwartungen
sind riesig aber
jetzt hören wir gerade bärbel bas
spricht daher noch mal kurz rein
offensichtlich gibt es ein ergebnis
und vielleicht ein paar vorbemerkungen
noch bevor ich das ergebnis der wahl
bekannt gebe
normalerweise ist es hier in dem saal
während einer laufenden sitzung nicht
erlaubt zu fotografieren
heute ist aber ein besonderer tag und
damit ich nicht
736 ordnungsrufe machen muss erlaube ich
gleich allen für diesen tag allen
abgeordneten
zu fotografieren aber bitte diskret
aber freuen sie sich nicht zu früh das
ist nur für heute
ab morgen gelten wieder die strengen
regeln
jetzt aber zum wichtigen teil ich gebe
das ergebnis
bekannt mitgliederzahl
736 abgegebene stimmen
ungültige stimmzettel 3
mit ja haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete
vielen dank wir können das gleich
weitermachen aber ich wollte noch das
andere die anderen stimmen zahlen
bekannt geben mit nein haben gestimmt
363 die erforderliche mehrheit von
mindestens
369 stimmen erreicht er ist gemäß
artikel 63 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
zum bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt
jetzt kommt aber die alles entscheidende
frage ich frage sie herr abgeordneter
scholz nehmen sie die wahl an
das verladung vernehmlich herr
bundeskanzler
ich gratuliere ihnen den namen des
ganzen hauses zu ihrer wahl auch
persönlich wünsche ich ihnen viel kraft
für die vor ihnen liegenden aufgaben und
das ergebnis der wahl werde ich jetzt
unverzüglich dem herrn bundespräsidenten
mitteilen und voraussichtlich um 12 uhr
findet die eidesleistung des
bundeskanzlers statt der wieder beginn
der sitzung wird auch rechtzeitig durch
klingeln signal angekündigt und jetzt
unterbreche ich die sitzung
[Applaus]
haben
ja gerade ist das ergebnis der wahl zum
neuen bundeskanzler
bekanntgegeben worden
olaf scholz hat die wahl angenommen er
hat ganz kurz und knapp auf die frage
der bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas ob
er die wahl denn annimmt einfach nur ein
knappes ja gesagt aber das war deutlich
zu verstehen es gab viele gratulanten
und gratulantinnen das sehen wir hier
sind auch noch nicht alle durch
vertreterinnen und vertreter aller
parteien haben gratuliert auch alice
beide haben wir gerade gesehen die olaf
scholz zum wahlsieg gratuliert hat es
gab blumen es gab auch einen obstkorb
und über diese wahl möchten wir heute
sprechen dazu haben der zdf
hauptstadtkorrespondenten nicole
diekmann die musste jetzt auch wieder an
position stehen da es sie jetzt weg
[Musik]
und da ist sie wieder da
matic foul
wir haben gerade gesehen ist an einem
langen applaus es gab standing ovations
für olaf scholz ist war ja dann obwohl
er ja wirklich einen mann der nicht nach
außen getragenen emotionen ist was er
eigentlich
moment wie hast du das gerade empfunden
ja ehrlich gesagt habe ich das hier
empfunden mitten in einer großen
menschentraube übrigens für die leute da
draußen ich trage keine maske um mich
herum alle kameraleute alle tun leute
alle die nicht vor der kamera stehen
tragen masken und wir sind alle nach
unserem status gefragt worden das
schicke ich mal einmal vorweg wir
standen hier in einer größeren traube
wir stehen ja hier im reichstag auf der
peene und hier steht so ein kleiner
fernseher auf den wir geguckt haben und
das ist ganz interessant hier ist die
hauptstadtpresse versammelt an diesem
tag ich habe das ja schon mal gesagt das
ist ja für uns die wir uns für politik
interessieren nicht nur beruflich
wie das champions league finale das wie
oder wie das wm-finale und hier
leute die diesen job seit jahrzehnten
machen seit vielen jahren machen auch da
hat man gemerkt das ist ein besonderer
moment ganz abgesehen von der ganz
unabhängig von der person olaf scholz es
gehen 16 jahre zu ende die ära merkel
endet heute nach 16 jahren kommt jetzt
ein neuer kanzler so man muss sich mal
vor augen führen alle menschen so unter
20 28 jahren in deutschland können sich
eigentlich nur erinnern an eine zeit in
der angela merkel chef in dieser
regierung war also dabei gehen jetzt
etwas neues und dementsprechend war das
hier oben
doch sehr still für kurzen moment was
für journalistinnen und journalisten ja
per se sehr ungewöhnlich und diese
stimmung übertrug sich auch ein bisschen
auf uns hier aus dem plenarsaal also
dieses feierliche moment da sitzt
natürlich auch leute
unionsleute ganz vorne mit dabei 16
jahre lang an der regierung weg gewesen
jetzt vom wähler in die opposition
geschickt für die ist das jetzt aus
parteipolitischer sicht kein freudentag
aber wie gesagt trotzdem es ist ein
besonderer tag es ist ein einschnitt
dazu schreibt banks auf youtube kurz und
knapp glückwunsch olaf und hofft
schreibt da kann man dem herrn scholz
beglückwünschen und ihm viel glück
wünschen denn das wird er brauchen bei
den derzeit bestehenden problemen
ich hab das wahlergebnis mitgeschrieben
die abgegebenen stimmen waren 700
77 107 abgegebene stimmen ungültige drei
es gab
369 jahr stimmen 303 nein stimmen wie
würdest du dieses abstimmungsergebnis
jetzt so ad hoc auf die schnelle
bewerten
wir haben ja die letzten 24 stunden alle
uns eine zahlenreihe eingeprägt wie
viele abgeordnete sitzen abgeordnete
sitzen in diesen neuen bundestag wenn es
noch richtig weiß hinter 736 wie viele
sitzen aus der ampel im bundestag das
sind 416 dh das war die zahl der stimmen
die olaf scholz hätte kriegen sollen um
das signal aussenden zu können meine
komplette regierung meine komplette
ampel sitzt steht hinter mir sitzt die
bundestag und steht hinter mir diese 416
stimmen hat er nicht bekommen aber mehr
als die 369 die erzählerisch für die
mehrheit brauchte um zum kanzler gewählt
zu werden jetzt ist eine entscheidende
zahl wie viele
abgeordnete heute hier fehlen und wie
viele ungültige stimmen abgegeben worden
sind erst dann kann man tatsächlich
zuverlässig sagen
olaf scholz hat diese 416 stimmt
definitiv nicht hinter sich versammelt
da gibt es also auch vereinzelt leute
aus den eigenen reihen entweder aus
reihen der spd relativ unwahrscheinlich
aus den reihen der grünen oder der fdp
die sich gesagt haben heute morgen kann
ich meine stimme leider nicht gegeben
hatte ich mir anders vorgestellt ich
hätte mir jemand anderen gewünscht genau
und ich muss mich gerade korrigieren ich
habe meine eigenen zahlen durcheinander
geschmissen
er hätte
369 jahr stimmen gebraucht und bekommen
hat er
395 so war es nämlich und ich hoffe ich
hab dich nicht damit aus dem konzept
gebracht wir schauen noch mal in den
chat mag schreibt so und das wird also
der nächste bundeskanzler ich wünsche
der neuen bundesregierung gutes gelingen
in einer nicht einfachen zeit maria
schreibt herzlichen glückwunsch olaf
scholz für unsere zukunft und ein bester
dank an die frau merkel benson schreibt
ich werde merkel vermissen hoffe
trotzdem dass olaf härter durchgreift
auch international china wird ein
problem werden ein großes problem und
wir haben demokratie feinde in unserem
land schön auch dass viele den neuen
kanzler auch immer einfach olaf nennen
das kennt man von der von angela merkel
kannte man das so auch nicht eine frage
eine frage von anklam er schreibt neuer
kanzler gewählt und die afg klatscht
nicht mal wie so hassen wie deutschland
ist natürlich schwer für dich zu
beantworten aber eine einschätzung gab
es ja keinen applaus
naja also die afg macht
fundamentalopposition
quasi seit ihrem bestehen nennt sich ja
so genannte alternative
das heißt sie grenzt sich ab von den
anderen parteien versteht sich eben
versteht sich selber inszeniert sich als
die einzige rechtsstaatspartei hier in
deutschland das heißt das ist eine
komplette abgrenzung teilweise ja auch
eine aggressive abgrenzung mit der
entsprechenden rhetorik bei allen
spielen bei allen farben spielen die es
nach dieser wahl gab ja total knapp
ausgegangen ist wenn man sich auf wenn
man sich die ergebnisse anguckt für
armin laschet cdu kandidat
beziehungsweise gemeinsamer kandidat von
cdu und csu
und olaf scholz es war eine knappe wahl
es wurde viel überlegt hin und her
überlegt mit wem spricht man mit ihm
spricht man mich man hat sich da auch
viel offen gehalten weil man wusste es
könnte knapp ausgehen schon im wahlkampf
aber es gab von allen parteien eine ganz
klare aussage mit einer partei werden
wir nicht reden und das ist die afd
und wir haben jetzt gerade gesehen dass
olaf scholz den plenarsaal verlassen hat
das heißt er ist jetzt auf dem weg ins
schloss bellevue zu bundespräsident
steinmeier dort wird er seine
ernennungsurkunde
genau also eine ernennungsurkunde
bekommen und dann kommt er wieder zurück
und gegen 12 uhr soll die vereidigung
dann stattfinden wir sind die ganze zeit
weiter dabei und weil olaf scholz jetzt
der neunte bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird und dass
wie du es eben auch schon gesagt hast
eine zäsur ist und ein stück weit auch
ein historischer moment und weil wir
vorher 16 jahre angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin hatten schauen wir uns
ihre vier vereidigung
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde so wahr mir
gott helfe
herr präsident ich nehme die wahl an und
bedanke mich für das vertrauen so wahr
mir gott helfe ich schwöre dass ich
meine kraft dem wohle des deutschen
volkes widmen seinen nutzen mehren
schaden von ihm wenden das grundgesetz
und die gesetze des bundes wahren und
verteidigen meine pflichten gewissenhaft
erfüllen und gerechtigkeit gegen
jedermann üben werde so wahr mir gott
helfe
16 jahre angela merkel und wir wollen
uns heute vor allem der gegenwart und
der zukunft widmen dem was die neue
regierung ja die ganze zeit als aufbruch
bezeichnet aber trotzdem noch mal ein
kurzes fazit wenn angela merkel jetzt
raus ist aus dem kanzleramt was bleibt
dann dennoch von ihm können
der jetzt erstmal
vorherrschende eindruck ist dass sie
gilt als eine kanzlerin die in einer
sehr sehr schwierigen zeit geht das hat
man letzte woche auch gemerkt auf ihrer
tatsächlich letzten mpk
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat es auf
der anschließenden pressekonferenz auch
gesagt angela merkel
angela merkels zeit als regierungschefin
endet mitten in der vierten und der
bisher massivsten dramatischen corona
welle sie tritt ab in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen zeit was
aber auch für die 16 jahre in dieses in
denen sie regiert hat steht das ist
relativ charakteristisch sie hat ja
mehrere krisen zu bewältigen gehabt
allen voran die sogenannte
flüchtlingskrise den großen flüchtlings
sommer 2015 2016 sicherlich ein
bedeutender teil ihres vermächtnis es
ist ja jetzt schon tja historische satz
den sie damals gesagt hat wir schaffen
das die euro krise viel in ihrer zeit
als bundeskanzlerin
also ja das ist das ende einer zeit in
der sie
sehr viele krisen zu bewältigen hatte
und deshalb vielleicht auch deshalb
sagen kritiker
sehr oft sicht gefahren ist also viel
tagesaktuell gemanagt hat und vor allem
in den letzten
23 jahren haben sich die stimmen gemehrt
die das bemängelt haben an ihr wenig
visionäre es noch angepackt hat
die welle gerade angesprochen
527 menschen sind in den vergangenen 24
stunden im zusammenhang mit 19 gestorben
du hast angela merkel viele jahre erlebt
wie bitter ist das für sie persönlich in
so einer situation
abzutreten
das ist natürlich bitter das ist
für eine kanzlerin sagt sie auch die ja
den als auch darauf geschworen hat
schaden vom deutschen volke fernzuhalten
natürlich kein schöner moment um zu
gehen das ist ja ein besonderer abschied
aus dem kanzleramt nämlich ein selbst
gewählter sie ist ja nicht abgewählt
worden sondern sie hat sich nicht noch
einmal zur wahl gestellt hatte dass auch
angekündigt dass sie sich nicht zur
wiederwahl stellt aber ich glaube man
muss keine politikerin kein politiker
sein um sich vorzustellen dass das sind
tatsächlich im moment ist in dem man
nicht gerne gehen möchte man möchte das
haus natürlich gut bestellt hinterlassen
das haus in dem bild das ich hier gerade
zeichne ist das land und das land ist
gerade vor allem in corona
hinsicht in keinem guten zustand im
gegenteil ich habe das waren ja schon
mal gesagt
die zahlen sind hoch die institute liegt
bei über 400 wir sind ja schon
erleichtert das muss man sich mal
vorstellen wenn innerhalb dieser 400
incidents das ist wahnsinnig hoch die
zahlen runter gehen und
es werden intensivpatienten werden hin
und her geflogen werden verlegt weil
sich auf den intensivstationen nicht
mehr vernünftig um sie gekümmert werden
kann das ist kein zustand den sich
irgendjemand wünscht und vor allem
niemand der dieses land 16 jahre regiert
hat und 3 corona welt zuvor eben auch
schon gebrochen hat
angela merkel hat ja bei ihrem
zapfenstreich gesagt im hinblick auf
ihre gesamte regierungszeit
dass sie ihren job immer mit
fröhlichkeit im herzen versuch dazu
machen das ist ein total schönes bild
was sie da gezeichnet hat hast du sie
auch erlebt oder hat man das in der
hauptstadt ihr journalistinnen und
journalisten habt ihr von dieser
fröhlichkeit im herzen die sie da
geschrieben hat habt ihr da kam das auch
oft rüber
naja also angela merkel ist ja ebenso
wie olaf scholz der er in mehreren
dingen ähnlich ist niemand die jetzt zur
temperament ausbrüchen neigt also die
trägt ihr herzlich auf der zunge die ist
sehr rational eher nüchtern
naturwissenschaftlerin die sie ja nun
mal auch ist also es ist jetzt nicht so
dass angela merkel hier fröhlich
trällernd pressekonferenzen abgehalten
hätte oder interviews aber gucken wir
mal zum beispiel auf ihre alljährliche
sommer pressekonferenz zu der die
bundespressekonferenz die vereinigung
der hauptstadtjournalisten unterlassen
sie eingeladen hat
nochmal sie hatte da immer wieder über
krisen zu berichten in diesem
zusammenhang ist ja auch der satz wir
schaffen das wird es der sogenannten
flüchtlingskrise gefallen das waren
keine einfachen veranstaltungen und auch
ohne diese krisen ist der job der
regierungschefin ja nicht immer
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig und trotzdem
blitzte immer der humor durch den man
ihnen nachsagt ein trockner ein sehr
feiner humor das hat man schon gemerkt
und
wenn sie sagt sie hat das mit
fröhlichkeit im herzen getan warum
sollte man ihr das nicht glauben sie hat
das immerhin 16 jahre lang getan und sie
ist nicht aus dem amt gejagt worden sie
ist aus freien stücken hat sie
entschieden es reicht jetzt nach 16
jahren
und du hast gerade schon gewisse
ähnlichkeiten zwischen angela merkel und
olaf als angesprochen lasst uns mal auf
die unterschiede schauen angela merkel
hat ihre art gehabt zu regieren was wird
denkst du alles anders machen
ja das ist das ist eine interessante
frage er hat ja eine personalie
verkündet vorgestern auf die alle sehr
gespannt gewartet hatten nämlich karl
lauterbach in sein kabinett zu holen als
bundesgesundheitsminister es gab in den
wochen zuvor
viele stimmen in der öffentlichkeit in
den sozialen netzwerken im übrigen auch
dass man sehr interessant zu verfolgen
die sich für karl lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister stark gemacht haben
nun weiß man aber karl lauterbach wollte
mein parteivorsitzender werden ebenso
olaf scholz beide sind es nicht geworden
lauterbach ist aber gegen olaf scholz
angetreten und das verhältnis der beiden
gilt als nicht exzellenz und trotzdem
hat olaf scholz ihn jetzt ins kabinett
geholt das ist interessanter - das zeigt
das freut sich von dem öffentlichen
druck ich habe es eben gesagt die eine
lesart war das kann ja jetzt nicht
machen weil das wirkt als wir der
einknicken vor der öffentlichkeit die
andere lesart war er kann das machen
weil er sogar ein genug ist und das hat
er gemacht
das könnte darauf hinweisen dass olaf
scholz da relativ zurück steht nicht nur
betreuer um sicherung versammelt leute
auch einbindet
qualifikationen das ist finde ich jetzt
schon charakteristikum dieses neuen
kabinetts dass er gebildet hat
nicole ich möchte ein lob von annegret
martha elisabeth an dich weitergeben so
schreibt auf youtube eure frau dieckmann
viel charme und humor zudem oft mutig
und schlagfertig
dankeschön das freut mich sehr das ist
schön und das soll ich auch vorbereiten
auf das kommende interview dass gleich
ansteht und motivieren der designierte
spd generalsekretär kevin kühn hat ist
auch schon bei dir neben dir ich drehe
mich mal um ich sehe hier sehr viele
mensch kevin kühnert sehe ich allerdings
nicht jetzt sekunde
wo ist er zeigt jemand wo ist er kevin
kühnert
kevin kühnert gibt gerade noch anderen
leuten ein interview man mag es nicht
glauben was ist denn hier los also er
ist schon in sichtbarer leer aber im
moment ist er anscheinend noch mit der
konkurrenz im geschäft alles klar du
lässt ihn nicht entkommen er weiß ja
dass er 20 fr 11 eigentlich bei uns sein
sollte so lange können wir mal ganz kurz
ins schloss bellevue schauen
und sehen dass wir im prinzip eigentlich
noch nicht wirklich viel sehen also
weder bundespräsident steinmeier noch
olaf scholz der gerade frisch gewählte
bundeskanzler ist sind da ein
tisch steht schon mal da und sobald sich
dieser saal füllt sind wir
selbstverständlich dabei gehen wir noch
mal zurück in den bundestag zu nicole
wir haben gerade festgestellt
da ist noch nicht viel los ich weiß
nicht ob du es auch sehen konntest wir
fragen einer alten und gut aber wie
gesagt es gab nicht wirklich viel zu
sehen ist auch viel los
mattes hat noch mal eine frage und
wollte nochmal auf diesen vergleich olaf
scholz angela merkel hinaus inwiefern
ist olaf scholz ein machtpolitiker also
vergleichbar mit angela merkel
also man wird nicht bundeskanzler wenn
man kein machtpolitiker ist das ist ganz
klar olaf scholz seit über 20 jahren im
geschäft war erster bürgermeister von
hamburg war bundesfinanzminister
hat sich in der spd nach oben gearbeitet
auch gegen viele widerstände
wir erinnern uns vor zwei jahren ist der
mann der heute zum kanzler gewählt wurde
vor wenigen minuten an der eigenen
partei gescheitert an den eigenen leuten
die wollten ihn nicht als ihren
parteichef
also durch und durch ein machtpolitiker
es klingelt niemand morgens an der tür
und fragt hätten sie vielleicht bloß
bundeskanzler zu werden das muss man
sich hart erarbeiten
absolut das thema der spd im wahlkampf
war ja vor allem soziale gerechtigkeit
und was da kommen wird und was nicht
kommen wird farblose la lie hat die
wichtigsten punkte zusammengefasst
die soziale gerechtigkeit schon immer
das kernthema der spd und auch diesmal
konnten sich die sozialdemokraten im
koalitionsvertrag in vielen bereichen
durchsetzen das wichtigste 12 euro
mindestlohn wird es künftig geben ohne
diese erhöhung hätte es die ampel wohl
nicht gegeben und die mietpreis bremse
bleibt nicht nur erhalten sondern wird
sogar verschärft rund 400.000 neue
wohnungen sollen pro jahr entstehen
100.000 davon öffentlich gefördert neu
eingeführt von der ampel eine
kindergrundsicherung kinder sollen
unabhängig vom einkommen der eltern
einen garantiebetrag erhalten wie hoch
der sein soll steht noch nicht fest die
neue regierung garantiert außerdem
rentenkürzungen oder ein frühes
rentenalter wird es nicht geben die
gesetzliche rente soll zudem um eine
aktien rente ergänzt werden ein
sogenanntes bürgergeld soll künftig
hartz 4 ersetzen doch auch hier ist noch
nicht klar wie hoch es sein soll
kritiker befürchten nicht viel höher als
jetzt hartz iv nicht überall konnte sich
die spd durchsetzen es wird keine
vermögenssteuer geben und keine erhöhung
der einkommenssteuer für
besserverdienende
ja nochmal ein hallo an alle die jetzt
zu uns gestoßen sind wir gehen in dieser
minute in stunde drei unseres streams
wir haben heute morgen um viertel vor
neun gestartet mit der eröffnung der
bundestagssitzung der wahl des
bundeskanzlers jetzt gerade ist der
frisch gewählte bundeskanzler scholz auf
dem weg ins schloss bellevue wo er dann
von bundespräsident steinmeier seine
ernennung stadt konnte bekommt und dann
wird er wieder zurück kommen in den
bundestag um seine verteidigungs formel
zu sprechen wir haben heute morgen mit
der journalistin und deutschland 3000
moderatorin eva schulz gesprochen annika
riedmann hat uns noch mal erklärt wie
frei ist future mit den klima
rettungsplänen der neuen regierung
umgehen wird und jetzt sehe ich dass
nicole diekmann unsere zdf
hauptstadtkorrespondenten den
designierten spd generalsekretär kevin
kühnert im interview
so ist es wir haben ihnen herausgefräst
er hat gerade den kolleginnen und
kollegen vom von der ard glaube ich ein
interview gegeben völlig in ordnung herr
natürlich dass sie jetzt bei mir sind
das ist für sie sicherlich ein großer
tag ja seit nach 16 jahren merkel wieder
ein spd-kanzler olaf scholz
welche überschrift wir kennen die
überschrift des koalitionsvertrags wer
fortschritt wagen welche überschrift
seit ihrer partei in dieser ampel tragen
wofür soll die spd in den nächsten vier
jahren gehen wir mal davon aus ist hält
vier jahre stehen für gemeinwohl soll
die spd stehen das ist der historische
auftrag aber auch ein ganz aktueller
auftrag ich glaube es reicht wenn man in
diesen tagen der pandemie in diesen
monaten und jahren der pandemie auf
unser gesundheitssystem beispielsweise
schaut wo wir doch sehen wie sehr die
verwertbar machen von allem und jedem in
unserer gesellschaft uns geschadet hat
unsere handlungsspielräume eingeschränkt
hat die gesellschaft zum schlechteren
verändert hat und daher dieses
gemeinwohl wieder zu stärken dass
politik auch darauf auszurichten dass
für die breite mehrheit die dinge
funktionieren da sehen wir unsere
aufgabe als spd
wahlergebnis war knapp
nun ist man in einer ampel war nicht das
wunschbündnis ist jetzt aber so jede
partei muss kröten schlucken wenn sie
koalitionen später etwas war die
schlimmste kröte was hat am meisten
wehgetan da werden unterschiedliche
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
unterschiedliche antworten wiegand frage
ich den sozialdemokraten kevin köhler
den habe ich nämlich gerade eben ist
absolut es ist sicherlich die sind die
fragen der vermögensverteilung bei denen
wir keine großen schritte vorankommen
werden wir hätten uns gut vorstellen
können der vermögenssteuer als
ländersteuer in deutschland zu
reaktivieren für sehr große vermögen die
häufig auch mit einer löchrigen
erbschaftssteuer weitervererbt werden
aber so ist das eben das haben wir nicht
hinbekommen wir haben dafür andere
sachen hinbekommen und das ist auch
gegenstand einer reifen demokratie am
ende sich nicht aus der verantwortung zu
stehlen und wegzurennen nur weil man
nicht jede kirsche auf der torte
bekommen hat die man sich gewünscht
hatte abrufe aus der verantwortung
stehen es gab gestern skurrile bilder
auf der einen seite hat man die
unterzeichnung dieser feierliche und
natürlich auch frohgemute unterzeichnung
des koalitionsvertrages gesehen auf der
anderen seite hier im bundestag
sondersitzung erster lesung
infektionsschutzgesetz da mussten sie
noch mal ran
da gab es viel kritik in den letzten
wochen dass auch die spd ihrer
verantwortung nicht bewusst nicht
nachgekommen sei dass man daher mehr
hätte machen müssen dass man das
schneller was hätte machen müssen und
das räumen ja auch alle ampelkoalition
er mittlerweile ein dass das kein
optimaler start war wie wollen sie das
vertrauen zurückgewinnen das sie schon
bevor die regierung überhaupt in amt und
würde gekommen ist eingebüßt haben bei
manchen mal vertrauen gewinnt man aus
meiner sicht am besten dadurch dass man
sich nicht zu fein ist dinge auch noch
einmal zu verbessern und zu korrigieren
dort wenn es notwendig ist für uns hätte
ist nach unserer überzeugung nicht jede
dieser änderung jetzt noch mal gebraucht
manches dient auch er der rechtlichen
oder endgültigen klarstellung dort wo
zwischen einzelnen ländern und der
jetzigen bundesregierung
unterschiedliche auffassung bestanden
haben was man eigentlich davon was nicht
mehr ministerpräsidenten erlebt die
haben sich mokiert über zu volle
fußballstadien in ihren ländern da ist
die ganz klare einschätzung das hätten
sie selber verhindern können haben sie
nicht getan ein seitenhieb auf die union
das muss dann auch ja oft nordrhein
westfalen in diesem fall aber so ist das
eben nichtsdestotrotz wir brechen uns
kein zacken aus der krone wenn wir sagen
wenn es dieser klarstellung nochmal
bedurfte dann tun wir das hier das haben
wir gestern in erster lesung gemacht
werden es diese woche noch zu ende
bringen und zeigt ihnen auch mal keine
neue regierung zustande bringen ohne
dass das tagesgeschäft was wichtig ist
im bonner zeiten darunter leidet
die impfpflicht ist ein großes thema
auch ihre partei hat diese endlich mal
kategorisch ausgeschlossen
diese kategorische dieses kategorische
nein ist jetzt hinfällig sie sagen na ja
das ist eine unwägbare pandemie deswegen
mussten wir da jetzt umsteuern wenn man
aber doch weiß wie unwägbar die pandemie
ist denn die impfpflicht debatte kam ja
erst dieses jahr auf ich glaube mitte
des jahres ungefähr warum machen so
erfahrene politiker die aus ihrer partei
den olaf scholz diesen fehler in der
kommunikation ein klares nein und kein
einschränkendes land sondern das ist ja
auch ein teil der der sogenannten
wortbruch debatte die gerade geführt
wird diese aussage ist ein fehler
gewesen und zwar unabhängig davon ob
jetzt wirklich eine allgemeine
impfpflicht am ende kommt oder nicht
denn sie es jetzt gegenstand der debatte
und schon das ist etwas anderes als in
aussicht gestellt gewesen ist ich glaube
wir vergessen immer in den hoch- und
tiefphasen der pandemie wie die stimmung
in der jeweils anderen phase gewesen ist
im sommer ist es jetzt zwei mal so
gewesen dass die rufe über laut gewesen
sind nach einem ende der pandemie nach
einem freedom day ausgerufen werden
sollte es war ihr koalitionspartner fdp
die besonders laut auch noch mal ja dass
man auch andere und dem haben einige
nachgegeben und dann etwas über dich
gesagt dass jetzt aber auch wirklich mit
dem ganz schlimmen phasen der pandemie
ende ist nur wir lernen wieder das
entscheiden wir nicht politisch wann die
pandemie vorbei ist sondern das
entscheidet die entschlossenheit mit der
wir maßnahmen ergreifen und das global
denn wir sind in einer pandemie die ist
per definition global und nur in
deutschland kriegen die sie nicht im
griff und deswegen ist das etwas wohl
vertrauen zurückgewinnen müssen jetzt
auch mit der neuen regierung das wird
auch in ihren zuständigkeitsbereich
fallen wenn alles so läuft wie sie sich
das erhoffen davon gehe ich mal aus
werden sie jetzt am samstag zum neuen
generalsekretär der spd gewählt und das
finde ich einen ganz spannenden punkt
sie haben versucht und sie hatten damit
erfolg
olaf scholz als spd-chef zu verhindern
das ist gerade mal zwei jahre her
sie werden wenn diese ampel gut regiert
wenn olaf scholz findet dass kanzler
sein spaß macht und ihm liegt sie werden
einen großen teil ihrer energie als
generalsekretär darauf verwenden müssen
ich hoffe auch wollen olaf scholz noch
mal kanzler fähig zu machen sie werden
seine kampagne organisieren müssen das
heißt derselbe mensch der vor zwei
jahren noch versucht hat oder short zu
verhindern wird versuchen ihn wieder
oder ihn seine wiederwahl zu
organisieren wie können sie den leuten
so eine inhaltliche 180 grad wende
erklären die sie da hinlegen zunächst
haben sie recht ich werde mit
leidenschaft daran arbeiten dass wir
auch die nächste bundestagswahl
erfolgreich bestreiten können ich würde
sagen die in der bundesrepublik
deutschland er nenne ich aufgrund des
artikels 63 absatz 2 satz 2 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland herrn olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler berlin den 8 dezember 2021
der bundespräsident und der unterschrift
herr bundeskanzler einen ganz herzlichen
glückwunsch
sollten wir die glaube ich noch mal
aufgeklappt in die kamera
so in einen herzlichen dank wir sehen
uns nachher wieder
lieber kevin kühnert liebe nicole
diekmann sorry für die unterbrechung
aber wir mussten gerade mal kurz ins
schloss bellevue rund übergeben weil
bundespräsident steinmeier olaf scholz
der nennung urkunde überreicht hat das
war eine relativ kurze angelegenheit die
beiden sind auch schon wieder raus und
damit bitte wieder report zu euch
vielen dank herr kühn hat ist
freundlicherweise bei mir stehen
geblieben diese gläser generalsekretär
der spd und da sind wir gerade verkündet
ich hatte sie eben gefragt sie haben vor
zwei jahren versucht olaf scholz zu
verhindern als parteichef jetzt werden
sie als künftiger generalsekretär daran
hart arbeiten dass er wieder gewählt
wird diese 180 grad wende die das ja
eigentlich bedeutet wer ist da
inhaltlich mehr auf ihn zugekommen sie
auch stolz der ihnen ja eigentlich zu
konservativ ist oder olaf scholz auf sie
die partei ist heute pragmatisch klarer
und zusammengerückt beispielsweise wenn
es um die sozialstaats fragen gingen
mehr mit der mutter andrea nahles schon
begonnen konzept zu arbeiten was unser
hartz4 trauma wirklich auflösen konnte
und darüber haben wir zueinander
gefunden auch die art wie olaf scholz
als finanzminister die krisen corona
krisenpolitik ökonomisch bearbeitet hat
also die bazooka an dem wir uns alle
erinnern das aussetzen der schuldenregel
das nutzen von investitionsspielräume
also das worüber wir lange jahre der spd
theoretische debatten geführt haben ist
man jetzt für schuldenbremse oder
dagegen bekam plötzlich einen ganz
realen sitz im leben denn es ging ganz
konkret darum was der staat in einer
notsituation nicht tun muss und in
dieser notsituation waren wir unseren
urlaub schuld bis zu den jusos alle
einig jetzt muss geklotzt und nicht
gekleckert werden und darüber ist
vertrauen zueinander gewachsen über
konkretes handeln parteitagsbeschlüsse
sind schön aber konkretes handeln ist
das was vertrauen wachsen lässt
sie beerben dann jahr voraussichtlich
lars klingbeil als generalsekretär der
wiederum zusammen mit saskia esken dann
die partei an der spitze weiter führen
soll als co- parteichef klingbeil ist
dafür bekannt sehr ausgleichenden
charakter zu haben sehr integrativ zu
sein
anpassungsfähig unglaublich freundlich
und konstant im auftreten nicht dass sie
unfreundlich werden aber sie sind eher
abteilung attacke
und haben auch im vorfeld schon gesagt
man musste sich nicht sklavisch an einen
koalitionsvertrag halten wie viel sorgen
muss ich denn olaf scholz machen dass
sie als generalsekretär seine
regierungsarbeit torpedieren da muss er
sich keine sorgen machen aber er weiß
eben auch dass die spd eine
diskussionsfreudige partei ist das wird
sie auch bleiben da bringt auch gar
nichts und wenn irgendwer von uns
versucht die partei dazu disziplinieren
und ich bin auch fest davon überzeugt
regierungshandeln wird langfristig nicht
leichter wenn man seine partei sediert
und dafür sorgt dass alle freudetrunken
sind aber nicht mehr über politik reden
das ist ja ein bisschen das was der cdu
in den letzten jahren passiert ist
freude über den machterhalt auf kosten
der programmatischen kärnerarbeit das
wird uns nicht passieren und da olaf
scholz sowie ich gelernter jurist weiß
er auch um diesen wesenskern der spd und
das hier gearbeitet werden muss es wäre
nur gut wenn die partei
auch an einem vorrat von ideen arbeitet
für vielleicht die ministerium zum
beispiel die wir nicht innehaben werden
in diesen vier jahren und dass ich nicht
die ganze zeit juzis mit lucys in den
haaren haben und das ist eine aufgabe
die dann hoffentlich auch meine in den
nächsten jahren sein wird was ja auch
nicht immer geklappt hat in der
vergangenheit letzte frage herr köhler
wir gehen davon aus dieses bündnisses
für vier jahre spielen wir mal vor 2025
wir beide stehen wieder hier
beziehungsweise wir stehen noch nicht
wieder hier wir sprechen kurz vom
wahlkampf miteinander
nach vier jahren regierungszeit was
glauben sie was werden sie in vier
jahren einräumen müssen konnten sie
nicht durchsetzen in der koalition mit
fdp und den grünen
eine vermögenssteuer zum beispiel damit
hatten wir einen ganz angefangen die
wird es wahrscheinlich auch am ende
dieser vier jahre nicht gegeben haben
bei den meisten anderen sachen würde ich
nicht meine hand ins feuer legen dass
wir sie nicht hinkriegen wird ich glaube
dass wir selbst bei denen die heute sich
nicht im koalitionsvertrag wiederfinden
wundersame überraschung erleben werden
weil vier jahre sind eine wilde zeit das
haben wir zuletzt erlebt und die
realität ist manchmal sehr viel bunter
als das was man auf 170 seiten in einem
koalitionsvertrag schlagen kann
optimismus also beim designierten
generalsekretär der fdp kevin kühnert
vielen dank herr kühnert und zurück zu
dir tätig haben
ja vielen dank kevin kühnert und nicole
diekmann und wir werden jetzt einmal den
journalisten und die da oben moderator
jan schepmann begrüßen vorher haben wir
noch einen beitrag den ich gerade suche
es geht um die
verkündung des wahlergebnisses das
gerade vor einer halben stunde verkündet
wurde das schauen wir uns noch mal kurz
an
ich gebe das ergebnis
bekannt mitgliederzahl
736 abgegebene stimmen
ungültige stimmzettel 3
mit ja haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete
vielen dank wir können das gleich
weitermachen aber ich wollte noch das
andere die anderen stimmen zahlen
bekannt geben mit nein haben gestimmt
363 hat die erforderliche mehrheit von
mindestens
369 stimmen erreicht er ist gemäß
artikel 63 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
zum bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt
jetzt kommt aber die alles entscheidende
frage ich frage sie herr abgeordneter
scholz nehmen sie die wahl an
das war laut und vernehmlich herr
bundeskanzler
ich gratuliere ihnen im namen des ganzen
hauses zu ihrer wahl auch persönlich
wünsche ich ihnen viel kraft für die vor
ihnen liegenden aufgaben und das
ergebnis der wahl werde ich jetzt
unverzüglich dem herrn bundespräsidenten
mitteilen
das war die bekanntgabe des
wahlergebnisses olaf scholz war jetzt
mittlerweile auch schon beim
bundespräsidenten im schloss bellevue
hat seine ernennungsurkunde bekommen ist
jetzt wieder auf dem weg zurück in den
bundestag und
die wird es da dann seine vereinigung
vereinigung formel brechen wir begrüßen
ihren chip man bei dem gerade mächtig
was los ist so lichttechnik ja jetzt
gerade das ging nicht auf disco
umgeschaltet ich habe absolut keine
ahnung warum aber ich würde gleich
nochmal versuchen druck zu machen
jetzt gerade aufgelegt ich guck das geld
am besten kommt dazu aber
ich habe
ich würde sagen ja weil es doch echt
schwierig da geht's ab gerade bei dir er
errichtete dein licht und ich frage mal
ganz kurz in der regie wieder bis dahin
weiter machen
nicole unsere pannen retterin horchte
war ja ich weiß nicht ob du gesehen hast
der hat gerade seine eine disco bei sich
im raum und insofern werden wir die zeit
mal wieder überbrücken wir zwei eine
frage an dich problem aber werde ich
kurzfristig einmal doch was sagen darf
ich haben gerade wo wir gerade beim
stichwort paten sind den hinweis einer
aufmerksamen zuschauerin die meint
gehört zu haben ich hätte kevin kühn als
als designierten
fdp-generalsekretär verabschiedet sollte
ich das getan haben ein kevin kühnert
die partei nicht gewechselt sondern
anscheinend die letzten zwei stunden
spuren hinterlassen im kopf er ist
natürlich designierter spd
generalsekretär so also tatsächlich mir
ist es jetzt auch nicht aufgefallen aber
wir stehen ja jetzt auch schon eine
weile hier insofern nein er ist
natürlich designierter spd
generalsekretär pd und alles andere wäre
mehr als eine eilmeldung wert gewesen
gut versteckt wir
stellen eine frage von thomas
spitzenberger auf youtube hat die neue
bundesregierung schon etwas zur
bekämpfung von hass und hetze in
sozialen netzwerken verlautbart dass da
irgendwas geplant
da finden sich tatsächlich einige wenige
aber immerhin absätze im
koalitionsvertrag die sind aber noch
relativ schwammig formuliert man muss
das leider so zu sagen da ist
deutschland ist aber international
sowieso ein riesiges problem damit ist
deutschland nicht alleine steht da noch
ziemlich weit am anfang das thema klappt
ja gerade wieder hoch dank telegramm der
plattform über die sich corinna leugner
extremisten im moment verabreden wir
haben diese entsetzlichen bilder gesehen
am wochenende dieser fackel aufmarsch
vor dem privathaus der sächsischen
ministerin
verabredungen zu solchen aktionen
finden zu einem großen teil auf
telegramm aber auch anderswo statt also
auch facebook und twitter sind jetzt
keine worte der seriosität
es gibt ja gesetzes initiative
beziehungsweise es gibt gesetze zb das
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz netz.de
2017 noch verabschiedet unter dem
damaligen spd bundesjustizminister heiko
maas aber das alles reicht vorne und
hinten nicht telegramm ist da noch mal
ein sonderfall das fällt leider gar
nicht unters netz.de aber wie gesagt
auch das ist kein wirklich
durchschlagskraft
im kampf gegen hass und hetze
dessen sich dieser ampel regierung
annehmen will aber wie konkret das ist
noch nicht so richtig klar einige hatten
ja auch auf ein eigenes digital
ministerium gehofft das ist vom tisch
das wird nicht kommen sondern wird
angesiedelt sein im verkehrsministerium
das thema digital ist beim fdp- minister
volker wissing
vielen dank nicole für den moment die
werden dann gleich wieder mit ihr
sprechen wenn du maria schröder von der
fdp zu gast haben
wir uns gleich wieder bis gleich und
jetzt begrüße ich ja nciht mann der sein
licht gerichtet hat und da gibt es
direkt eine frage von wilma ist ja nciht
man da war ich ebenso irritiert von dem
blitzlicht dass ich dich gar nicht
richtig vorgestellt habe du wirst auf
der einen seite journalist und auf der
anderen seite moderator des funk formats
die da oben hallo ja schön dass sie bei
uns bis in eurem format ist euch ja ganz
wichtig dass ihre politik möglichst
nahbar und eben auch nachvollziehbar
überbringt wie würdest du denn jetzt auf
eine art und weise die kernziele der
neuen regierung zusammenfassen
progressivität würde ich jetzt einfach
mal sagen also erst mal hallo
entschuldigung dafür dass für dringlich
das ist glaube ich gerade ein bisschen
in panik modus auch gewesen ich glaube
dass die kernziele
ja ein fundamentaler baustellen umfassen
zum einen sieht man das in der
gesellschaftspolitik aber auch in der
sozialpolitik
wird es nach diverse änderungen geben
die man auch aktiv spendet
nochmal die erinnerung an unsere
userinnen und user schreiben sie uns
ihre fragen gerne in die
kommentarspalten jetzt auch an jan oder
schicken sie uns eine mail an der
adresse die jetzt hoffentlich gleich
unten wieder eingeblendet wird wir
versuchen soviel wie geht zu beantworten
und zu diskutieren
ja ich würde gerne mal mit dir das
kabinett durchgehen da geht ja doch zum
einen oder zur anderen einiges zu
erzählen und zwar
müsste ich das jetzt auch an kriegen
wir wollen
ihn haben wir gesehen er ist jetzt
gerade wieder auf dem weg zurück in den
bundestag um vereidigt zu werden müssen
jetzt nicht darüber reden hier
wirtschaft und klima robert habeck was
fällt dir zu ihm ein
erstmal ist es ein großer vorteil aber
nach dass die grünen es geschafft haben
denn das den klima teil mit in
wirtschafts ressort anzusiedeln weil das
ja eine große chance ist halt einfach
wirtschaft und klima zu verbinden und
einfach klimaschutz dazudenken wo es
essentiell passieren muss man vergisst
auch dass der bereich energie im
wirtschaftsministerium angesiedelt ist
gleichzeitig ist natürlich eine riesige
herausforderung
die wirtschafts zufrieden zu stellen und
gleichzeitig die öffentlichkeit die
gerade im klimaschutz sehr auf die
finger schauen wird da wird einiges
passieren und robert haben auch schon
gesagt dass hinter jeder ecke ärger
landwirt von daher bin ich sehr gespannt
wie sich das entwickelt und robert
habeck wird ja auch vizekanzler eben
nicht annalena baerbock was ist das für
ein zeichen
man sagt ja dass die beiden sich
abgesprochen haben dass wir aber kannst
keine daten wird aber im falle einer
niederlage
hw klang der zugriff auf die
vizemeisterschaft bekommen sollte
sollte das der fall sein ich das
vollkommen ok und respektabel das ist so
geregelt haben gehen wir mal weiter
christian lendner finanzminister das
waren ganz schönes gerangel war nicht
ganz klar dass er das bekommt ja ich
glaub das war aber also ich bin mein
realistisch gesehen hätte sich die fdp
die chance nicht nehmen lassen das
letzte mal die fdp teil der regierung
geworden ist soll angela merkel gesagt
haben niemals hätte ich der fdp das
finanzministerium gegeben dieses mal hat
die fdp hat wirklich darauf bestanden
und lindner hat einen spagat schaffen
auf der einen seite keine
steuererhöhungen auf der anderen seite
große investitionen die anstehen da
ist muss halt geld reinkommen und das
soll unter anderem auch über private
investitionen passieren aber auch wir
auch schon angekündigt hat über ein
konsequentes durchsetzen des
steuerrechts hattest du dich dann gegen
steuerflucht da bin ich auch gespannt ob
man das studium merken wird
gehen wir weiter annalena baerbock wird
außenministerin am werden hier vor ein
paar tagen frau professor weil die
gesagt hat die außenpolitik die
internationale politik in der regierung
wird weiblich und dass sie das sehr gut
findet ja für alle ist sie als
völkerrechtlerin das heißt das ist schon
mal eine wirklich gute sache und
zweitens hat die dann wirklich großen
fokus darauf gelegt also auch im
koalitionsvertrag ist zumindest foreign
policy festgeschrieben worden was
bedeutet dass gerade auch frauen mehr an
diplomatischen prozessen beteiligt
werden sollen und das wirkliche politik
wenn glaube ich zu heiko maas
ja irgendjemand hat auch heute morgen
gesagt dass oder irgendwo habe ich
gelesen dass die idee die fußstapfen so
riesig während von heiko maas das war
natürlich ein fieser tritt unter die
gürtellinie machen wir weiter
karl lauterbach karl lauterbach das war
glaube ich die entscheidung oder auch
weil sie eben so spät bekannt gegeben
wurde ja es ist natürlich eine große
chance es ist vor allem auch ein großer
druck da gewesen jemand auf die position
zu setzen der ist wirklich auch aus dem
aus dem fach kommt es da andere seite
ist eine riesige fallhöhe weil
lauterbach natürlich mit dem ganzen
medienrummel super viel aufmerksamkeit
mitbringt und wenn er es schafft die
partie im griff zu kriegen dann fällt er
ist auch direkt auf uns zurück es ist
eine
personalentscheidung ja die irische
risiken birgt
lassen wenn man im moment bei kalbach
bleiben denkst du dass das auch der
grund warum diese entscheidung oder
diese bekanntgabe der entscheidung so
lange gedauert hat
einer davon aber nicht der einzige also
ich glaube dass da in der partei auch
wirklich viel diskutiert werden musste
die personalentscheidungen auch durch
die die parität die olaf scholz zugesagt
hat und
es gibt ja zwei spieler binden wir sind
noch zu kommen sehr überraschende
verschiebung auch im vergleich zum alten
kabinett beispielsweise christine
lambrecht die als innenministerin
gehandelt wurde dann der ist doch auf
die verteidigung gehen soll also da gab
es noch einiges zu diskutieren und die
auch glaube ich da sind ein paar
entscheidungen bei der er so last minute
gefallen sind also aber noch wird
definitiv auch eine davon gewesen sein
olaf scholz hat ihnen ja vorgestellt als
bundesgesundheitsminister mit den worten
dass sich viele gewünscht haben dass der
nächste gesundheitsminister vom fach ist
und es auch wirklich kann also es war
volle breitseite gegen jens spahn aber
die fallhöhe ist natürlich jetzt auch
relativ hoch und die erwartungen an karl
lauterbach sind riesig genau und man
darf nicht vergessen dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister sich auch an
sich schon infektionsschutz gehalten
gesetz halten muss und dass er jetzt
nicht einfach in eigenregie hat diese
pandemie mit harter hand niederknüppeln
kann das heißt die erwartung muss er
halt auch erstmal erfüllen können im
rahmen seiner möglichkeiten
er bleibt bei uns ich höre gerade dass
nicole diekmann im bundestag jetzt rea
schröder von der fdp als interviewgast
hat
ganz genau jessica vielen dank du hast
es gerade schon gesagt er ja schröder
ist jetzt bei mir ehemalige chef der
jungen liberalen der julis beisitzerin
im parteivorstand der fdp und seit
dieser legislatur auch hier im bundestag
hat er frau schröder danke dass sie bei
uns sind ich denke es ist ein großer tag
für sie heute ja fdp wieder mit in der
regierung eine partei die ja
zwischendurch nicht mal mehr im
bundestag vertreten war
ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen wasser
in den wein schütten
es sind die minister ministerin noch
nicht vereidigt es gab schon viel kritik
in den letzten wochen was das management
der korona pandemie angeht wie wollen
sie diesen fehlstart wieder wettmachen
was muss jetzt passieren damit sie das
vertrauen zurückgewinnen ich sehe es
nicht als stadt die alte regierung war
im amt die konnte handeln und wir haben
trotzdem auch schon mit den ampel
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag
schritte eingeleitet die notwendig waren
die aus meiner sicht auch genau richtig
waren dass wir jetzt den turbo zünden
auch diese woche das ist längst
überfällig das hätte die alte regierung
schon längst tun
und müssen wir machen das jetzt da gibt
es viel aufzuholen aber ein fehlstart
ist es nicht sondern wir tun jetzt das
was notwendig ist klar aber sie schärfen
ja nochmal nach wir haben sondersitzung
diese woche hier im bundestag und
bundesrat also
das wird ja auch mittlerweile offen
kommuniziert aus den reihen ihrer partei
dass man da vielleicht doch von anfang
an ein bisschen hätte die zügel anziehen
müssen auch beim thema impfpflicht sagte
parteichef christian lindner bei diesem
kategorischen nein bleibt es nicht mehr
7 70 prozent haben die kollegen von der
ard ermittelt der fdp wählerinnen und
wähler sind mittlerweile für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht haben sie da ihre
wähler haben sie sich verschätzt in dem
was ihre wähler wollen oder haben sie
sich verschätzt was die pandemie angeht
was die entwicklung der pandemie
betrifft die pandemie ist eine lage die
sich ständig verändert und man muss dann
wenn es notwendig ist das richtige tun
wir führen jetzt die debatten erst mal
über die impfpflicht für bestimmte
einrichtungen wo menschen geschützt
werden müssen die sich nicht selber
schützen können die besonders von der
arge sind das halte ich für den
richtigen schritt und dann unterhalten
wir uns auch über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht das sind genau die debatten
die wir jetzt führen müssen wir haben
das ja im letzten jahr erlebt das immer
wieder die mpk irgendwas neues
beschlossen hat jetzt führen wir diese
debatten im deutschen bundestag da wo
sie hingehören vom freedom day den ja
auch ihre partei gefordert hat zur
debatte über eine allgemeine impfpflicht
sie haben weiten weg zurückgeführt
zurückgelegt und sie muss natürlich wie
alle anderen parteien auch kröten
schlucken was den koalitionsvertrag
angeht welche zwar die schmerzhafteste
für mich persönlich war die
schmerzhafteste kröte beim thema
rente das ist ein thema was ich als
chefin der jungen liberalen auch immer
stärker in den vordergrund gestellt habe
gesagt habe wir müssen dazu einem
systemwechsel kommen wir haben jetzt den
systemwechsel ein stückweit eingeleitet
es kommt ein teil kapitaldeckung aber es
gibt bereiche das renteneintrittsalter
an dass wir nicht so mutig angegangen
sind wie ich das für nötig keiten hätte
wir haben den den großen umsturz auch im
demografie system vor uns in den
nächsten jahren also da wird noch viel
darüber zu reden sein also es gibt
wermutstropfen aber ich will auch den
blick darauf lenken was gut ist und wir
werden in ganz vielen bereichen gerade
auch beim thema bildung was mir sehr am
herzen liegt jetzt große schritte voran
gehen können viele dinge die einfach
jetzt überfällig waren auch im
gesellschaftspolitischen bereich die
kommen jetzt und darüber freue ich mich
sehr
generationengerechtigkeit war ja
tatsächlich immer schon ihr thema
welche überschrift welcher kern soll die
fdp ausmachen in dieser koalition die ja
keinem in dieser in dieser ampel vorher
als wunschkoalition vorgeschwebt wofür
soll die fdp explizit stehen in diesem
dreierbündnis die fdp stehen für mutige
entscheidungen für entschlossenheit für
marktwirtschaft da haben wir auch
manchmal so ein bisschen reibungspunkte
mit den koalitionspartnern und auch für
für fortschritt ganz besonders weil wir
müssen dieses land nach vorne bringen es
gibt so viel zu tun und wir packen das
jetzt an in welchen punkten konkret was
ist da fdp typisch das sieht man so ein
stück weit natürlich auch schon an den
ministerien die jetzt von der fdp belegt
werden das thema bildung ganz stark
vertreten durch bettina stark watzinger
im bereich digitalisierung wo wir volker
wissing haben wo wir im moment viel zu
tun haben leider immer noch in
deutschland wo wir jetzt aber große
schritte gehen können und natürlich auch
beim thema stärkung der marktwirtschaft
er hat auch das thema finanzen natürlich
eine große rolle gespielt wir haben
steuererhöhungen nur verhindern können
steuersenkungen die auch notwendig
werden um die wirtschaft anzukurbeln und
ihnen die freiheit zu geben die sie
braucht auch um die notwendigen
investitionen gerade beim klimaschutz zu
tun das ist was das müssen wir uns fürs
nächste mal vornehmen oder daran müssen
wir weiter aber ich glaube da haben wir
ganz wichtige ministerien auch besetzt
die jetzt auch ganz wichtig werden sie
haben stark abgesahnt bei den jungen
wählern und wählerinnen eben nicht wie
die grünen und die haben sie gerade
schon erwähnt bettina stark watzinger
die in diesem ministerium für bildung
zuständig sein wird die einzige frau die
die fdp an die spitze eines ministeriums
setzt sie wollen stehen für
fortschrittlichkeit mehr fortschritt
wagen ist ja die überschrift dieses
koalitionsvertrages das digitale haben
sie auch nicht ohne grund an sich
gezogen das ist ja auch ein kernthema
der fdp warum sind sie im bereich der
parität der gleichstellung von männern
und frauen der gleich besetzung
zahlenmäßig von von ministerium und
warum hat die fdp das nicht geschafft
oder gemacht sie wissen dass es mir ein
wichtiges anliegen dass frauen auch den
zugang bekommen zu politischen
entscheidung dass sie mit am tisch
sitzen ich glaube wenn es dann um
konkrete personalentscheidungen geht
dann darf das aber nicht wichtiger sein
als die kompetenz und ich glaube nicht
dass wir nicht auch kompetente frauen
gehabt das wäre jetzt mal eine frage
gesagt aber wir haben die ministerien
die welt gesetzt haben mit wirklich ganz
großartigen persönlichkeiten besetzt und
wir haben auch bei den anderen parteien
beobachten können wie die in
schwierigkeiten kamen aufgrund dieser
quotenregelung und wo dann vielleicht
auch manchmal jemand nicht in der
regierung gelandet ist den man da
gesehen hätte und ich glaube das ziel
von parität das darf keine bremse sein
sondern es muss eine möglich macher sein
und da haben wir viel zu tun das bleibt
auch weiterhin ein thema auch für die
fdp in allen strukturen auf allen ebenen
aber ich würde jetzt nicht in einem
kompetenten mann und wir haben da drei
zumindest dann werden wir jetzt gleich
machen denen irgendwie ein stein in den
weg legen und sagen ihr makel ist dass
sie keine frau sind sondern dass sie
wirklich ganz großartige
persönlichkeiten den hervorragenden job
machen werden letzte frage wir gehen
jetzt mal davon aus die ampel hält vier
jahre man regiert miteinander und wenn
ich sie am ende der legislatur noch mal
im interview habe was würden sie sagen
was ist der punkt von dem sie jetzt
schon ausgehen den werden sie als fdp ob
sie obwohl sie es gerne würden in dieser
ampel nicht durchsetzen können
also ich würde sehr gerne dass wir eine
grundlegende reform des
bildungsföderalismus in deutschland
erreichen sehe da aber probleme gerade
im bundesrat auf uns zukommen deswegen
werden wir daran arbeiten müssen auch
mit einem digital pack 2.0 wir werden
auch gespräche für mit der kmk mit den
ministerpräsidenten und präsidenten kmk
ganz kurzer sind die kultusministerin
und kurz genau also da werden wir viel
probieren ob wir aber zu einer
grundgesetzänderung kommen die ja dann
auch die zustimmung benötigt da mache
ich noch ein fragezeichen dran aber ich
werde auf jeden fall daran arbeiten
schreiber den vier jahren auch mal
drüber vielen dank herr schröder von der
fdp und zurück zu jessica
vielen dank nicole diekmann und rea
schröder und nicole wenn ich das auf
meinem zettel richtig sehe dann hast du
als nächstes ronja kemmer dann von der
cdu dann kommen wir wieder zu dir über
wir werfen einen blick in den bundestag
der ist noch leer das heißt olaf scholz
ist noch nicht angekommen und sobald er
dann wieder da ist um die verteidigung
zu sprechen schalten wir natürlich
wieder in den bundestag das werden sie
bei uns nicht verpassen jetzt wieder zu
die da oben moderator jan chapman januar
ist wieder da sehr schön jetzt bist du
wieder weg
ich höre dich und jetzt sehe ich nicht
ob das
an der wand gerade bei karl lauterbach
stehen wir leben den am kann man hier an
der seite sehen machen wir mal direkt
weiter da hatten wir glaube ich alles
gesagt ja hier
innenministerium nancy faeser
spd ist hieß das sei ein echter coup
gewesen von scholz einer
der
aussagekräftigsten entscheidung von
chance weil er sich aktiv gegeben hat
und entschieden hat die schale
regierungserfahrung hat oder auch sogar
erfahrungen hat sondern hat gesagt
womit jemanden klaren kurs nancy faeser
hat in hessen sehr intensiv und
konsequent gegen den rechtsextremismus
angekämpft hat in den dns
untersuchungsausschuss als obfrau
begleitet hat der untersuchungsausschuss
zu hano mit eingesetzt und ist wenn ich
im kopf habe seit zwölf jahren hat
scholz bei der vorstellung gesagt
innenpolitische sprecherin der fraktion
und hessen die sie jetzt auch leitet das
heißt er hat sich da die man geholt die
sich im zweifelsfall auch mit dem
verfassungsschutz
anlegen würde und dass das ist eine
ansage so
eine kurze zwischenfrage an dich bands
und schreibt auf youtube dass du vor
kurzem auf twitter erklärt hättest dass
du kein großer fan von olaf scholz wärs
und er fragt wem du lieber an der spitze
gesehen hättest und warum ich habe
gesagt ich bin kein riesiger fan boy von
olaf scholz aber ich finde es sehr schön
wie er das konsequenz und geräuschlos
durchzieht und die politischen gegner
verzweifeln lässt daran das war ein
etwas ironische bemerken dazu
ok damit
beantwortet arbeit und soziales hubertus
heil spd
jetzt keine große überraschung der wird
seinen job einfach weitermachen
genau ist der einzige der auf dem alten
job bleiben darf das hat er auch sehr
konsequent und auch unter sehr sehr
schwierigen voraussetzungen gut gemacht
der hat in der kantine das kurze
watschen dadurch gebracht die die
grundrente ist ein großer erfolg für die
spd gewesen dass lieferketten gesetzt
was kurz vor knapp am ende noch
durchgegangen ist es ein großer erfolg
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass er in
dieser legislatur auch noch mal einiges
mehr durchsetzen kann weil viele
vorhaben auch ja
an der union gescheitert sind
insbesondere am peter altmeier im
wirtschaftsministerium von daher bin ich
sehr gespannt was er alles schaffen wird
eine zwischenfrage von marx auf youtube
sind überhaupt irgendwelche posten mit
leuten besetzt die sich auch mit dem was
sie jetzt entscheiden eine ahnung haben
ok also ein bisschen schwierig
formuliert aber ich glaube es wird jetzt
was er malt verschiedene leute sehr viel
ahnung von dem was sie da machen da bin
ich mir sicher und insbesondere das heil
hat das jetzt letzten diktatur wirklich
gut bewiesen
gut dann schauen wir weiter wenn haben
wir noch ja die neue
verteidigungsministerin wird christine
lambrecht heißen sie war vorher
justizministerin und hat dann auch noch
kurz vor der sommerpause das
bildungsministerium von franziska giffey
übernommen damals im familienministerium
vielen dank und entschuldigung beim der
dann damals zurückgetreten war genau
genau und das ist tatsächlich eine
relativ überraschende entscheidung von
scholz gewesen wie es auch lamprecht
selber gesagt hat dass das er als
überraschend kommt sie hat gesagt sind
für sie es ist ein großer
vertrauensbeweis und ja auch eine große
herausforderung
interessanterweise ist wie die einzige
person wo scholz nicht mit fachthemen
begründet hat warum sieht dieses
ministerium bekommen hat sondern einfach
weil ich kann weil sie weiß wie man
ministerien leitet und sie war ja
eigentlich als innenministerin angedacht
so viele so viel haben zumindest die
meisten
journalistinnen vermutet und das hätte
sinn gemacht als justizministerin hat
sie konnten spiegel ministerium zum
innenministerium besetzt und hat auch
viele kompetenzen da gehabt die auch im
innenministerium wirklich von vorteil
gewesen werden jetzt macht das
verteidigungsministerium was halt auch
wirklich nicht ein zeit passt und
ministerien ist da gibt es immer wieder
skandale gerade rechtsextremismus aber
auch ausstattung der truppe das schießen
gewerk kommen oder vierten teil gar
nicht mehr also dass da gibt es einige
stolpersteine und ich glaube da ist oder
scholz die die kompetenz ein großes
kompliziertes ministerium zu führen am
wichtigsten gewesen genau das
verteidigungsministerium gilt als harte
nuss da sie haben auch verschiedene
politiker und politikerinnen auch schon
echt schwierigkeiten mit gehabt bei
christine lambrecht war es ja auch so
dass sie in der in der laufenden
legislaturperiode dann von katharina war
damals übernommen hatte war gar nicht
von anfang an dabei scheint aber
irgendwie in ihre ihre läden gut im
griff zu haben ist das vielleicht auch
manchmal wichtiger als ja vom fach zu
sein
ich glaube es kommt ein bisschen aus
ministerium an das
verteidigungsministerium wurde jetzt in
den letzten jahren nie von drücken
geleitet jetzt irgendwie aus der
bundeswehr irgendwie kommen
das ist auch auf seiten der fall und ich
glaube eine verteilungs ministerium geht
es auch wirklich viel um einen überblick
über verschiedene zuständigkeiten im
koordination und in diesem fall hat
lambrecht das sicherlich in der
vergangenheit gut gemacht und gerade
auch jetzt als als ich vom gipfel ist
meine familie ministerium noch
übernehmen musste beziehungsweise
angeboten hat das unternehmen hat sie
das auch sehr geräuschlos und kompetent
weiter geführt also ich glaube dass
wir schauen weiter wenn marco buschmann
justizminister wird das amt eben von
christine lambrecht übernehmen und
dieses ministerium ist an die fdp
gegangen richtig marco buschmann hat ja
jetzt gerade insbesondere den letzten
wochen keine so einfache zeit gehabt
gerade was corona anging er hat sich
insbesondere den letzten jahren sehr
stark gegen die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite ausgesprochen hat
gesagt dass es den bundestag in den
kompetenzen übergangen wird dass politik
eigentlich quasi nur noch in mp cars
gemacht wurde und deswegen war es ihm
aber auch der fdp ein anliegen diese
epidemische lage zu beenden das kam
natürlich zu einer zeit wo die korona
lage immer wieder stress gegangen wurde
wo die vierte welle hoch gegangen ist da
muss man gleichzeitig sagen jeden sparer
auch geplant die epidemische lage zu
beenden aber jetzt gerade bleibt es an
der fdp hängen ob da nicht vielleicht
die krone situation auch unterstützt
worden ist
und dann treiben ja direkt weiter
wo waren marco buschmann fdp ja
familienministerin wird ein spiegel von
den grünen die hatte man eigentlich als
bundesministerin auch nicht so wirklich
auf dem schirm
da sehen wir damit zu tun dass bei den
grünen ja wirklich auch einige
personalentscheidungen anders gekommen
sind als man gedacht hatte da gibt es
die divergenz zwischen den reales und
den linken flügel und es musste da ein
bisschen auf die parteistrukturen
geachtet werden nichtsdestotrotz hat
anne spiegel in der vergangenheit auch
gezeigt dass sie
ja sehr
dickes fell hat in rheinland pfalz und
da auch da gab es tatsächlich den fall
dass sie ein zweites ministerium dazu
genommen hat als es den skandal gab in
rheinland pfalz als ich glaube die
ehemalige umweltministerin in rheinland
pfalz das amt verlassen musste und da
hat spiegelt dann auch zwei ministerium
geleitet
und dann hätten wir da noch cem özdemir
der bekommt das ministerium für
ernährung und landwirtschaft von den
grünen und
erzählt auch das ist nicht ohne ohne
travel gelaufen genau also ich meine
investiere dann muss man muss man sagen
es gibt keinen bei den grünen der
besseres ergebnis eingefahren hat bei
dieser bundestagswahl hat 40 prozent der
erststimmen geholt seinen wahlkreis und
das ist halt ne ansage und
gleichzeitig auch die einzige person und
wirklich mit dem wirklichen
migrationshintergrund im neuen kabinett
das sind schon zwei faktoren warum man
ihn meiner meinung nach nicht hätte
begehen
jetzt ist es so dass bei den grünen ja
nicht nur die links beziehen sie die
links realo komponente da ist aber auch
die parität sehr sehr wichtig gesehen
ist deshalb wurde der sehr sehr viel
diskutiert und im endeffekt hat sich
erste mir gegen hofreiter durchgesetzt
was natürlich auch zu unmut im linken
lager der grünen geführt hat aber ich
würde sagen was du mir ist jemand der in
der vergangenheit gezeigt dass sehr
verlässlich
und auch in vielen bereichen viele
ahnung hat nichtsdestotrotz hätten
es ist eher so dass das er für den fall
dass die grünen das verkehrsministerium
gekriegt hätten da die erste wahl
gewesen wäre und manche hätten auch
gerne im auswärtigen amt gesehen die
bild hat getitelt warum kriegt berbalk
putin und erste mir puppen deswegen gab
es da so ein bisschen und drüber aber
ich glaube dass er als
landwirtschaftsminister dass auch
vernünftig machen können
damit hättest du die frage von marx vom
orc haben schon beantwortet was von mir
zu erwarten ist aber ahmed möchte noch
wissen wie du bewertet das statt einem
biologen ein sozialpädagoge
landwirtschaftsminister geworden ist ob
da nicht was falsch gelaufen wäre
ich meine hofreiter wer hat biologe
gewesen das hätte er sicherlich auch gut
ausfüllen können und dabei auch ein
kandidat der es hätte machen können
gleichzeitig ist die jagd landwirtschaft
ökologie ist eine kernkompetenz von von
sehr vielen grünen und erst jetzt wird
es ganz ganz ganz vielen jahren dabei
der hat die expertise auch also ich
glaube das ist eine sache die auch an
gelernt ist bei ihm mittlerweile das
heißt dann würde ich wenig auf seine
persönliche ausbildung gehen ich würde
gerne nochmal zurück gehen kurz zu
christine lambrecht
verteidigungsministerium der liesl
schreibt auf youtube das sie erwartet
dass unsere bundeswehr nicht weiter
kaputt gespart wird und das zukünftige
auslandseinsätze besser überprüft werden
das desaster in afghanistan sollte man
nicht vergessen
ja das sind zwei verschiedene punkte die
sie auch beide bei der vorstellung
angesprochen hat man darf nicht
vergessen der verteidigungsetat ist nach
wie vor der zweitgrößten deutschen
bundestag der stadt jedes jahr aber
trotzdem ist es so dass da auch
strukturell einiges passieren musste der
bundeswehr dass das hat sich
angesprochen und klar afghanistan ist
eine riesige zäsur meiner meinung nach
muss es sein dass leibrecht gesagt wird
jetzt muss über exit strategien
gesprochen werden das wundert mich das
sollte man vielleicht ein paar jahre
vorher war
lasst uns doch mal putin und toten das
erinnert mich jetzt unweigerlich an
diese an den titel neue merkel variante
setzt sich durch da muss ich noch mal
vor zu olaf scholz damit auch das bild
dazu passt
siehst du in olaf scholz eine merkel
variante
ich glaube dass er
zwar bemerken gut zusammengearbeitet hat
respekt vor zusammengearbeitet hat aber
andere schwerpunkte setzen wird und
dass er seinen eigenen stil
weiter durchziehen wird und auch
konkretisieren wird jetzt muss ich
einmal ganz kurz in die regie fragen ob
wir ronja kemmer von der cdu schon bei
nicole diekmann stehen haben
noch nicht okay
wir können weitermachen sekunde pro
wagen haben wir schon haben wir schon
immer schon haben wir schon haben wir
schon fangen wir schon ach ja hier
volker wissing verkehr und digitales fdp
sich in der großen belastung dass die
grünen das verkehrsministerium sich
nicht halten konnten das fdp
durchgesetzt hat das hat sicherlich auch
damit zu tun dass das ist kein separates
digital ministerium gab dass das sind
digital teilen wird im
verkehrsministerium angesiedelt ist und
dass da so ein bisschen
das eine der ersten prioritäten auf
nicht-wissen habt den job in
rheinland-pfalz ja schon gemacht hat
sich aber so ein bisschen die nesseln
gesetzt jetzt 3 erster hand
amtshandlungen er war einer derjenigen
der zwar vor den verhandlungen auch
immer betont hat oder wer behandlung
auch dass das spiel so toll wäre dass
alle für inter halben stehen müssten
jetzt hat er direkt als eine der ersten
großen interviews nachdem bekannt wurde
dass der verkehrsminister wird der bild
gesagt dass er so ein bisschen die diese
erfahrung mit samthandschuhen anfassen
wird dass es einen ausgleich zu hören
diese steuern über die kfz steuer geben
wird was überhaupt nicht so
festgeschrieben ist das steht im
koalitionsvertrag das wird geprüft da
gibt es also noch keine einigung und da
waren die grünen natürlich ziemlich
sauer darüber und das sind auch so ein
bisschen dieser aussagen dieser den
koalitionsfrieden stören können gerade
wenn es jetzt gerade erst anläuft
da bin ich mal gespannt normalerweise
ist eigentlich jemand der dafür bekannt
ist dass er auch wort hält und auch sehr
konsequent am koalitionsvertrag arbeitet
und die tatsache dass ist kein eigenes
digital ministerium geben wird wie
würdest du das bewerten also rea
schröder hat ja eben in dem interview
auch schon gesagt dass sie eigentlich
wirklich sehr bedauert dass es
bis jetzt noch keine grundlegende reform
des bildungswesens gibt war eben was
auch dieses digitalisierungs thema
angeht
sind zwei bereiche also gerade hat er
den den bildungsföderalismus
angesprochen das ist eine hauptprobleme
glaube ich auch dafür dass ja weil bei
den bundesländern ist in
unterschiedlichem tempo tempo voran geht
ich glaube dass
das ein anderes als ein anderer
schwerpunkt ist das digitale ministerium
hätte sehr sehr viel arbeit gebracht man
hätte wirklich bis das betriebsfähig
wäre so wäre eineinhalb bis drei vier
jahre ins land gegangen ich habe dazu
mit robert habeck interview geführt der
meinte hätte seine großen zweifel gehabt
was das ziel führend gewesen wäre und
ich habe aus der fdp zumindest gehört
dass auch christian endter da seine
zweifel daran hatte ob das so eine gute
idee ist
kommen wir noch mal stichwort christian
lindner
finanzministerium da schreibt hagen auf
youtube also ich hoffe dass christian
lindner hat zu seinem wort steht und für
uns eine in anführungszeichen
ermöglichung ministerium administriert
karl würz brauchen
ja ich glaube dass man musik das
ministerium jetzt kann pandemie
bekämpfung das gar nicht der geldkarte
gar nicht so im vordergrund steht das
saß das geld saß wenn man mal auf die an
die in die masten verteilaktionen denkt
von jens spahn auch in der
bundesregierung der relativ locker karl
wird er definitiv
mit blick auf eine pflegereform ihn
brauchen aber das ist ein anderes thema
genau das war eben auch die anspielung
darauf dass das finanzministerium eben
auch ein vetorecht hat wir machen weiter
mit umwelt und verbraucherschutz steffi
lemke von den grünen eine der wenigen
ostdeutschen in der lage zwei aus
deutschen tatsächlich
was prozentual so gefällt kommt ja der
bevölkerungsanteil der ostdeutschlands
ist um 15 prozent in deutschland jetzt
sind ungefähr zwölf prozent im kabinett
aber ich glaube dass sich da einige
größere repräsentation gewünscht hätten
steffi lemke gilt als eine sehr
konsequente naturschützerin hat den
sachsen anhalt sich namen gemacht auch
bei der letzten kenia koalition bei den
verhandlungen gilt als eine sehr
konsequente naturschutz darin ist das
beste team kompakt studierte
agrarwissenschaftlerin die hat arno von
dem sie gemacht
wir gehen noch einmal zurück zur volker
wissing da kam nämlich noch eine frage
das kommt ein bisschen zeitversetzt
teilweise bei uns daran dass das aber ja
kein problem da haben ja zeit
die frage lautet wird wissen eine
koexistenz zwischen autos und öpnv
schaffen können
er hat betont dass er an welt an alle
verkehrsteilnehmer in einem sein will
das heißt ich gehe davon aus dass der
koalitionsvertrag hat ja auch
konkrete pläne was das angeht also ich
gehe davon aus dass jetzt keine an die
steuer zwar gute politik gemacht wird
und dann schauen wir noch mal weiter ja
das ministerium für bauen und wohnen
soll es glaub ich heißen klara geywitz
spd ist ja eine frühere weggefährtin
genau jetzt 2009/10 sicher mit ihnen für
den spd vorsitz beworben das hat nicht
geklappt jetzt kriegt sie das einzige
neu geschaffene ressort baut war früher
im innenministerium mit angesiedelt da
wurde ein bisschen spöttisch aus der
bau- und immobilienwirtschaft auch schon
gesagt das hat man nicht gemerkt die
gruppe wird auch ihre ziele von 1,5
millionen wohnungen bis ende dieses
jahres verstehen tatsächlich das denn
wahrscheinlich 300.000 wohnung weniger
werden sagt man als geplant und das ist
ein bisschen ein fingerzeig dass es die
die bau- und wo politik bei der ampel
eine größere priorisierung bekommen soll
und halt mit am kabinettstisch in dieser
sitzen soll
und wir kommen noch mal zurück zu volker
wissing
daniel schreibt wird bis ich es schaffen
die co2 emissionen der autos so weit zu
senken um die freiheit zukünftiger
generationen zu schützen
alleine wird eher das nicht schaffen
aber natürlich der verkehrssektor
wichtiger nach der so weit ich weiß nach
der energiewirtschaft die
zweitwichtigste in diesem land da muss
einiges passieren aber dass das hat auch
viel mit einem bahnausbau zu tun wir
übrigens ausbau zu tun das ist nichts
was man von jetzt auf gleich mal gerade
die planung von neuen bahntrassen muss
deutlich
verlegt werden das kann teilweise sechs
jahre dauernden und das ist auch keine
sache die wirklich in dieser legislatur
durchgezogen werden kann dass auf einmal
ein projekt vorbei ist aber es muss
jetzt dringend angestoßen werden
klara geywitz haben wir gerade
besprochen
bildung und forschung bettina stark
watzinger am fdp eines von den vier fdp
ministerien und da wird dieses thema
bildungsföderalismus auch noch mal eins
sein
ja definitiv die fdp hat sich ja schon
öfters kritisch gegenüber des
bildungsföderalismus
geäußert und ich behalt viel von stark
watzinger ich glaube dass sie in eine
gute wahl ist für das ministerium
persönlich und was die fdp ja schon seit
einiger zeit gefördert hat eine bafög
öffnung der flexibilisierung auch ein
elternunabhängiges bafög das ist der
teil des koalitionsvertrags da mussten
sie aber auch keine große türen
einrennen weil das wollen die grünen und
die spd in der form auch gerne das heißt
dann wird sich einiges tun und gerade
und digital 2.0 gerade bei der
ausstattung der schulen aber auch bei
der weiterbildung von lehrkräften wird
auch einiges passieren wo der bund
tatsächlich auch über die eigene
leistung den ländern auch noch unter die
arme greifen kann
mano formuliert auf youtube eine
erwartung an die ministerinnen und
minister
die neuen minister sollen ihren stab
nicht nur ökologisch betrachten sondern
auch sozial gerecht und nachhaltig
denkst du dass das so quer durch die
bank auch funktionieren wird
das ist der anspruch ich gehe davon aus
dass das mal mehr mal weniger
wird aber ich glaube dass sich alle nach
ausrichten unterschrieben werden
wir schauen weiter
entwicklungsministerium svenja schulze
spd jetzt auch kein neues gesicht in der
regierung
das ist meiner meinung nach eine
ziemliche degradierung sie war früher
hörten welt ministerin das resort ist
weg das haben die grünen
und jetzt hat sie im ministerium was da
muss man sagen nicht so hoch angesehen
ist es gab immer wieder diskussionen
jetzt auch vor dieser vor dieser
bundesregierung ob man das überhaupt
noch beibehalten möchte oder ob man das
nicht entweder im umweltministerium oder
im auswärtigen amt mit ansiedeln möchte
das hat den hintergrund dass der etat
bei etwas über zehn milliarden liegt was
ich glaube immer um die 12 was mal
irgendwas knapp 6 fache formen vom
umweltministerium ist und dass durch die
klima investitionen man sich da
sicherlich gerne an diesem geldtopf noch
mit bedient hätte aber es ist
beibehalten worden und es ist vor allen
dingen auch im ministerium
wo hat themen behandelt werden die ja
auch emotional sind also gerade hunger
in der welt dessen sache dann kann man
muss man was bewegen gerd müller als csu
minister hat das vorher tatsächlich sehr
sehr geräuschlos und auch über die
fraktionen hinweg sehr geschätzt gemacht
ich bin gespannt ich glaube dass schulze
gute wahl ist diesen sehr diplomatisch
person weiß wie das auf dem
internationalen parkett funktioniert ist
hat sie jetzt in glasgow gezeigt
also ich denke schon dass du da keine
großen probleme haben wird eine
besserung du hast
angesprochen dass das möglicherweise
eine degradierung
ist wahr dass wenn ja schulze als
umweltministerin olaf scholz zum
wirkungslos
naja das umweltministerium ist dann die
grünen gegangen das war klar dass das
nicht nehmen lassen würden und die
regierungszeit müssen gesagt aber das
umweltministeriums höher angesehen und
wichtiger als das als das
entwicklungsministerium und das oder
spende schützen weiter im kabinett haben
möchte das ist ja das ist bekannt dass
es sicherlich auch für sieben der
wertschätzung sie war ja im gespräch und
man hat genug top sie nicht das
bauministerium bekommen würde und klara
geywitz das entwicklungsministerium was
tatsächlich für mich auch nicht so
clever gewesen wäre wenn der schütze
hatte ja gerade weil hatte ja bei
energetischer sanierung und bei
umweltschutz anbau was auch klara
geywitz angesprochen der vorstellung ja
auch schon in ihrem alten ressort
gefordert und deswegen hätte ich mir
auch vorstellen können dass sie auch das
bauministerium gut hätte auswirken und
dann haben wir zum schluss noch den
kanzleramtsminister wolfgang schmidt spd
das ist so nahm so kann's ja so ein
ministerium was immer mal gerne so
hinten runter fällt vielleicht kannst du
zum einen zu dem ministerium was sagen
und zum anderen auch was so wolfgang
schmitz denn der ist ja jetzt noch
weitgehend unbekannt genauer schmidt ist
eine der längsten weg von olaf scholz
sei es als spd-generalsekretär als
arbeitsminister als hamburger
bürgermeister unterholz den hans
minister schmit immer dabei und es hat
er hätte scholz den rücken frei
das kanzleramt ist so ein bisschen so
die schnittstelle die für die konvention
zwischen andere ministerien aber man
darf nicht vergessen dass beispielsweise
der bundesnachrichtendienst denn
kanzleramt unterstellt ist also es immer
das feld sie müssen hinten runter aber
ist es nicht unwichtig und gerade jetzt
helge braun ist ja auch in der krone
pandemie immer mehr in den fokus
getreten der freude den job ausgeübt hat
von daher ich gehe davon aus dass es
nicht so unwichtig ist und sein wird wie
es viele denken ja
nackt für den moment bleibt weiter bei
uns und wir geben jetzt noch mal nach
berlin in den bundestag denn nicole
diekmann spricht jetzt mit der
opposition
sie hat ronja kemmer von der cdu
ganz genau danke jessica ronja käme
steht neben mir ronja käme ist noch
ziemlich jung aber schon seit 2004 10 im
bundestag war damals die jüngste
abgeordnete und ist dann auch naturgemäß
möchte man fast sagen zur chefin gewählt
worden der jungen gruppe im bundestag
das sind wenn ich es richtig weiß 15
abgeordnete aus cdu und csu fraktion
unter 35 richtig frau käme danke dass
sie heute bei mir sind frau käme ich
frage jetzt sie als cdu politikerin
nicht als demokratisch
ist das heute ein bitterer tag wenn man
also in die opposition geschickt wird
und ein s p hat jemand zum kanzler
gewählt ja natürlich hätten wir uns ein
anderes ergebnis heute gewünscht und
hätte gern hätten gern ein cdu-kanzler
gewünscht aber es gehört dazu eine
demokratie natürlich gratulieren wir
olaf scholz und wir werden jetzt aus der
opposition die zweitschönste aufgabe
entsprechend diese rolle wahrnehmen
was macht eine gute opposition aus was
wird die unionsfraktionen in den
nächsten vier jahren
charakterisieren außer einem neustart
und einer neufindung ich glaube auf der
einen seite klar kritisch zu sein das
ist nun mal die aufgabe als opposition
aber auch konstruktiv zu sein und
wirklich auch nicht nur zu motzen sage
ich mal so das motzen willen sondern
auch klar aufzuzeigen wo haben wir
inhaltlich bessere alternativen und das
ist die große aufgabe
wenn sie sagen konstruktiv es gab ja
auch aus den stimmen der cdu oder aus
den reihen der cdu stimmen die gesagt
haben neuer weite teile des
koalitionsvertrages hätten auch von uns
sein können
wo finden sie sich wieder im
koalitionsvertrag von spd grünen und fdp
also was ich persönlich wirklich franz
oder gut zum lesen fand war der ganze
zahn rund um das thema
staatsmodernisierung das ist eine
riesenaufgabe aber wir können das halt
nicht einfach mit einem gesetz
beschließen deswegen wird die spannende
frage sein wie bindet man ländern ein
wie macht man es mit den kommunen und
das werden wir jetzt kritisch
entsprechend begleiten war ganz so
einfach ist die aufgabe eben nicht was
wollen sie in den vier jahren machen
dass ihnen eine erneute wie niederlage
sagen wir mal in den nächsten vier
jahren regiert die ampel hält also die
legislaturperiode durch was wollen sie
anders machen in vier jahren was muss in
den nächsten jahren passieren dass sie
wieder attraktiver werden für die
wählerinnen und wähler ich glaube wir
müssen uns breiter aufstellen zum einen
inhaltlich aber auch personell wir
müssen was heißt inhaltlich breiter das
heißt dass wir glaube ich themen die in
der regierungsarbeit mal liegen
geblieben sind das passiert einfach in
16 jahren da ist einfach viel
tagespolitik nummer das maßgebliche dass
wir uns jetzt mal auch da der opposition
wirklich frei gedanken machen können was
erwarten wir zum beispiel beim thema
zukunft der sozialen sicherungssysteme
so ein thema das man nicht irgendwie mal
kurz in fünf minuten löst und da glaube
ich haben wir jetzt auch die möglichkeit
des frei das neu zu denken out of the
box und dann müssen wir auch glaube ich
mut beweisen ich glaube das ist die ganz
große sache um die es geht dass wir auch
mal mutig sind einfach dinge ganz neu
anzugeben sind auch zwei drei mehr
themenfelder wo sie sagen da müssen wir
wieder ran das hat ein bisschen gelitten
in den letzten jahren in
regierungsverantwortung
ich glaube tatsächlich dass eine thema
klimaschutz da haben wir viel gemacht
aber wir haben es nicht transportiert
bekommen was unsere konzepte und ideen
sind und beim anderen thema
digitalisierung auch da ganze breite der
gesellschaft in vielen fragen die die
systeme einfach auch betrifft und ich
glaube das sind so die zwei großen mega
themen einfach jetzt auch für die
nächsten jahre sie stehen jetzt hier
neben mir auch auch als chefin der
jungen abgeordneten von cdu und csu
die jungen wählerinnen und wähler haben
sich entweder in richtung fdp gewendet
oder in richtung grüne warum
beziehungsweise wie wollen sie das
anders machen wir wollen sie die für
sich begeistern also das gute ist ja
vier jahre zuvor waren wir noch stärkste
kraft aber wir haben viel vertrauen
verloren ich glaube wegen diskussionen
wie artikel 13 um anderen deswegen ist
gedanken noch einmal für unsere zuhörer
was artikel trat genau es ging um die
frage wie gehen wir mit dem ganzen thema
upload filter um es war eigentlich eu
thema das aber dann auch runtergebrochen
ist auf die jungen gesellschaft in
deutschland
und deswegen geht es einfach glaube ich
drum um die art und weise vor allem wie
wir kommunizieren dass wir solche
botschaften eben nicht mehr per pdf
beantworten sondern eben über soziale
kanäle ist das ist ein riese und zu den
ab laut väter noch mal da hat die cdu
den koalitionsvertrag gebrochen ein
versprechen gebrochen
in der umsetzung wenig letztendlich gar
nicht so unzufrieden wie es damals
angeklungen dass in den anfangs
diskussionen aber ich glaube der große
fehler war jetzt nicht nur in der
inhaltlichen debatte wo man
verschiedener meinung sein kann sondern
die art und weise wie einfach
kommuniziert wurde und dann finde ich
gibt es schon parallelen auch zum thema
wieso aber nochmal das sind viele dinge
die wir glaube ich besser machen können
die wir auch erkannt haben und deswegen
braucht aber auch eine breite
aufstellung in partei und fraktion und
das ist auch ganz klar unsere
forderungen auch jetzt gerade wir sind
ja jetzt an dem punkt wo in der fraktion
viele entscheidungen anstehen und da
wollen wir natürlich auch nicht nur
gehör finden sondern auch dass unsere
jungen abgeordneten sich da wieder
finden sagt deren chefin ronja käme
chefin der jungen gruppe der gemeinsamen
fraktion von cdu und csu im bundestag
vielen dank frau kemmer dass sie heute
hier waren und zurück zu dir jessica
auf die opposition wir gehen dann
nochmal zu ja schippmann wir haben noch
ungefähr zehn minuten zeit gegen 12 uhr
soll die vereidigung des neuen
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz stattfinden
ja wir waren ja die ganze zeit bei der
neuen regierung und in der zwischenzeit
möchte ich dir auch vor folgendes nicht
vorenthalten
florentine schreibt danke für den tollen
und informativen live stream das
schreibe ich jetzt mal uns allen auf die
fahne und mork vom ork schreibt aber
kompliment an schippmann guter
einordnung naja da
gerne weiter so lassen wir sind jetzt
alle ministerinnen und minister
durchgegangen und lass uns über parität
sprechen die spd hat ja die parität
erreicht wie versprochen die fdp hat den
schnitt dann muss man sagen ein bisschen
kaputt gemacht hatte er aber auch klar
gesagt sie legen da nicht den
allergrößten wert darauf jetzt sind es
neun männer und acht frauen würdest du
sagen dass der geschlechter mäßig
trotzdem was erreicht wurde
das sind fragen wir uns rechnet stolz
bin stolz ist raus nimmt dann ist das
eine andere sache ich glaube der
anspruch wäre tatsächlich gewesen im
besten fall tatsächlich auch mehr frauen
als männer zu haben das ist glaube ich
auch nicht schlecht gefunden aber klar
ist dass ein versprechen von gewesen bei
den grünen ist sowieso in der dna drin
die fdp hat gesagt gut wenn
und das verspricht der muss halt das
selber irgendwie
durch drücken wir senden die leute ran
bedenken die machens am besten hätte
jetzt die fdp das verteilungsnetz tieren
gekommen wäre zum beispiel marie agnes
strack zimmermann noch ins spiel
gekommen da wäre es vielleicht dann auch
zwei männern zwei traum gewesen
aber ich glaube schon dass das jetzt
schon erfolgt ist und
ja ich freue mich darüber es gibt aber
trotzdem eben auch kritik weil es heißt
dass es eben zuwenig ostdeutsche
politiker innen gibt aber das hatten wir
ja eben schon mal angesprochen
genau prozentual ist das tatsächlich
sehr ähnlich abgebildet also wie gesagt
nächsten ungefähr zwölf prozent des
kabinetts versus 50 prozent ostdeutsche
bevölkerung
ich verstehe aber auch die kritik dass
eigentlich weil im osten natürlich immer
noch sehr große baustellen sind und wenn
man jetzt gerade sieht das auch ja dass
das gefühl was sich immer wieder in
umfragen abbilden lässt dass man ja ich
sag mal bürger zweiter klasse ist das
ja das sieht man natürlich auch an
infrastruktur das sieht man an der
lohnentwicklung und es hätte sicherlich
nicht geschadet da noch
ein zwei leute im osten mehr einzuholen
zumal es da auch fähige leute gibt ich
glaube aber zwischen wegen carsten
schneider der jetzt ostbeauftragte
werden soll der hat so was stark auf dem
schirm das ist eine sache mit der er
sich sehr viel beschäftigt hat kommt zu
wenig also sie haben
das glaube ich auch gut machen und da
auch einen großen fokus
wir sehen dass der bundestag der
plenarsaal sich so langsam wieder füllt
wir haben das im auge und sobald es an
die vereidigung des bundeskanzlers geht
werden wir auch direkt wieder rüber
gehen solange das noch nicht der fall
ist haben wir noch zeit und john
schreibt nochmal zur parität es solle
nicht um das geschlecht gehen sondern
einzig und allein um die kompetenz der
säge bekommt den job egal ob mann oder
frau das war ja so ein bisschen die
argumentation der fdp bei der besetzung
ihrer posten
ich glaube das ist unfähige frauen gibt
auch durch durch die parteien dreck um
diese jobs auszufüllen von daher ist das
argument natürlich klar soll kompetenz
da sein aber ich sehe da kein
kompetentes vakuums
und was für das so sagen insgesamt wie
würdest du das neue themen bewerten
ich bin sehr positiv überrascht und ich
freue mich tatsächlich drauf ich bin ich
sehr gespannt insbesondere auf habeck
und linda wie ihren job machen werden
weil das sind die beiden die die werden
es den nächsten recht machen können also
lindner geht braucht jeder der wird auch
nicht bei jedem projekt jahren abend
sagen können und würde auch öfters mal
um frieden auf sich ziehen müssen arbeit
ist diese divergenz zwischen klimaschutz
und wirtschaft die ja vor von 32
unterwegs ist die beiden da bin ich sehr
gespannt
was würdest du nachher geben hier gibt
der hier gibt es jetzt eine richtige
diskussion sehe ich gerade hier linux
schreibt es geht nicht um mann oder frau
es geht um kompetenz und um männliche
seilschaften okay
warum sie hat ja immer dass er ja das
große thema bei parität also ich muss
dann wenn man jetzt sagen würde es sind
alles sehr sehr kompetente männer und
alles in kompetente frauen und jetzt
sind erste hälfte gesetzt das ist es
strom an aber das ist nicht der fall ist
durch die parteien wirklich dass das
genau richtige kommt denn die männer wie
frauen gerade bei denn eine partei die
auch wirklich großen frauenanteil haben
dass das sieht man jetzt auch gerade
steffi lemke jetzt geht das einfach sehr
sehr versierte frauen ihren bereich so
dass es für mich ist es halt immer so
eine sonder sondern soll ali die
diskussion ich glaube einfach dass es
gut ist dass das 50 50 im besten fall
abgebildet wird und ich glaube das ist
in beiden bereichen kompetenz dann halt
gehen muss andreas scheuer hat gezeigt
dass man das kompetenz im job über
das ist jetzt nicht so als hätten gerade
in der in der letzten bundesregierung
die frauen wäre enttäuscht so das ist
halt ich finde schwierig und ich freue
mich darüber dass das jetzt anders
gekommen ist in der neuen
bundesregierung dass es gut aufgeteilt
ist und ja das muss ich dann halt wir
sehen dass sich der plenarsaal
langsam füllt wir sehen auch die
designierten ministerin und minister die
daneben im anschluss an die vereidigung
von olaf scholz ins schloss bellevue
fahren werden dort ihre
ernennungsurkunden bekommen werden und
dann wieder zurück in den weg kam und
dort vereidigt werden also dass es die
prozedur und so wird's gemacht
bundestagspräsidentin bärbel bas ist
jetzt zumindest schon an ihrem platz wir
haben das im auge es geht dann jeden
moment los und so lange schreibt uns
hanna altmann dass es aus bayern
überhaupt kein minister gibt und dass
sie dazu noch keine beschwerden gehört
hätte
naja ich meine claudia roth ist
staatsministerin das wird würde begangen
das jetzt keinen penck eine ministerin
für sie aber sie kommt aus bayern und im
endeffekt als ministerin genau richtig
und ich glaube das
kommt vor kurzem die oppositionsarbeit
aus cdu/csu und aber sprechen das ist ja
kurz normal leben angekommen jetzt sucht
sich die csu insbesondere da irgendwie
angriffs felder die eigentlich keine
sind es sind auch aus anderen
bundesländern keine minister innen da
und natürlich hat die csu da ihren
bayern fokus ist es über die jahre
hinweg sehr sehr viel bayern in der
bundesregierung vertreten gewesen ich
finde das absolut nicht argument genauso
wie diese unsägliche diskussion dass das
cdu und csu teilweise die ampel so links
geld nennen das ist eine von populismus
wenn man nach spieler diese alten
links-grün idee an und das ist keine
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit meiner
meinung nach da fehlt noch einiges ich
find ronja kamera kleben da haben wir
gar nicht nur geredet hat das sehr
selbstkritisch ja wieder gegeben man
muss sagen dass deutliche roderich
kiesewetter sehr sehr diplomatisch und
gut dass die die die ampel kommentiert
haben armin laschet hat heute auch noch
mal gesagt
als demokrat ist es doch wirklich stark
das ist einfach eine schöne einfachen
übergang vermacht gibt man kann sich
freuen dass der respekt unter demokraten
da ist das finde ich auch sehr
respektabel das muss man sagen aber
gleichzeitig gibt es dann auch diese
eher kindischen stimmen aus cdu und csu
die jetzt gerade echt noch so ein
bisschen
trotzdem
und dann muss nach 16 jahren vielleicht
auch die neue rolle auch erst noch mal
gefunden werden wir sehen olaf scholz
ist jetzt wieder im bundestag
eingetroffen
das bedeutet es kann nicht mehr allzu
lange dauern bis er dann auch als
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland vereidigt wird
die
bundeskanzlerin merkel also angela
merkel hat ja immer die vereinigung
formel mit den worten so wahr mir gott
helfe abgeschlossen wie wird das olaf
scholz halten weiß dass ich weiß es
nicht gerd schröder da machst verzichtet
und was tatsächlich ein bisschen
ungewohnt sein wird ist tatsächlich hat
das dass angela merkel ja dann auf der
besuchertribüne sein werden muss also
kann halt nicht kein handschlag
beglückwünscht bzw das wird
wahrscheinlich durch chor ohne regelung
galt aber
nur um auch einfach dass sie heimlich
abtritt und nicht geschlagen worden ist
das sind einige änderungen in den
prozeduren absolut das erklären wir
vielleicht einmal kurz besitzt um auf
der tribüne weil sie ja keine gewählte
abgeordnete mehr ist sie es ja nicht
mehr angetreten in ihrem wahlkreis und
deshalb sitzt sie oben und deshalb wird
es dann auch einen moment dauern bis sie
dann runter kommen kann und ihm
gratulieren kann jetzt sehen wir wie
olaf scholz am fortschritt zur
bundestagspräsidentin und
was bedeutet das
ich würde sagen wir
haben mal kurz rein
[Applaus]
die unterbrochene sitzung ist wieder
eröffnet ich rufe auf den
tagesordnungspunkt
31 leistungen des bundeskanzlers
der herr bundespräsident hat mir mit
schreiben vom heutigen tage mitgeteilt
gemäß artikel 63 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland habe ich heute herren
abgeordneten olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler ernannt
nach artikel 64 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes
leistet der bundeskanzler bei der
amtsübernahme vor dem deutschen
bundestag den in artikel 56 des
grundgesetzes
vorgesehenen
herr bundeskanzler ich bitte sie zur
leistung zu mir zu kommen
herr bundeskanzler
ich halte die urschrift des
grundgesetzes in meinen händen ich bitte
sie die in artikel 56
vorgeschriebene eidesformel zu sprechen
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz
eine schlechten gewissenhaft erfüllen
und gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben
werde
vielen dank ich danke ihnen viel glück
für ihre aufgabe
meine damen und herren ich stelle fest
dass der herr bundeskanzler den
vorgeschriebenen eid vor dem deutschen
bundestag geleistet hat herr
bundeskanzler ich darf ihnen auch noch
mal auf diesem wege für alle ihre
aufgaben alle guten wünsche mit auf den
weg geben
die sitzung wird voraussichtlich um 13
uhr 30 mit der bekanntgabe der vom
bundespräsidenten ernannten mitglieder
der neuen bundesregierung und ihrer
vereidigung fortgesetzt der widder
beginn der sitzung wird rechtzeitig
durch klingel signal angekündigt ich
unterbreche die sitzung
das war jetzt
auf der einen seite feierlich auf der
anderen seite eher kurz und schmerzlos
die vereinigung von olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland und jan wie wir gerade
gelernt haben er hat es ohne die formel
die worte so wahr mir gott helfe
gesprochen
wie schon vor ihm dass er gegen
geschieht damit wollen wir uns ganz
herzlich bei dir bedanken toll dass du
mit uns das neue regierungsteam durch
gegangen bist und uns eine ganze weile
begleitet hast vielen dank und besucher
uns bald wieder bei zdf arte live
danke sagte und
damit kommen wir zu nicole
diekmann im bundestag die auch weiter
tapfer bei uns ist an unserer seite
nicole jetzt ist es tatsächlich so dass
die ära merkel zu ende ist und olaf
scholz ist der neue bundeskanzler
jetzt ist es passiert
genau würde wolfgang schäuble jetzt
sagen der neue bundeskanzler ist olaf
scholz jetzt geht der geht die zeit der
berufspendler hier weiter scholz war ja
eben schon im schloss bellevue und
beim bundespräsidenten und hat sich
seine ernennungsurkunde
abgeholt jetzt erst kann stolz sein
kabinett benennen denn jetzt erst ist er
ja wirklich kanzler und dieses kabinett
durchleuchten dasselbe prozedere die
sitzung hier sitzt erstmal unterbrochen
für ungefähr eineinhalb stunden und wird
dann wieder fortgesetzt
und wir sehen wie im bundestag jetzt
noch selbst gemacht werden es wird
gratuliert und allgemein scheint die
stimmung sehr gut zu sein ich schaue
noch mal kurz in den chat was wir da
bekommen haben
ich habe gerade jetzt finde ich die
frage nicht mehr aber ich habe vorhin
gesehen eine
schulklasse schaut uns zu
eine neunte klasse habe ich gerade
gelernt herzliche grüße wir freuen uns
dass er die ganze zeit dabei seid und da
war die frage nicole ob die neue
regierung die 2 gb beziehungsweise 3g
regelungen auch aufrechterhalten will
naja also die letzte mpk ist ja noch
nicht so lange her
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
da ist es beschlossen wurde letzte woche
noch mal und es würde mich sehr wundern
wenn sich daran jetzt etwas ändern würde
das wäre erstens arbeitstechnisch nicht
sehr effektiv sich stundenlang
zusammenzusetzen etwas zu beschließen
und ist eine woche später wieder
abzuräumen und zweitens warum also die
zahlen haben sich nicht wesentlich
verändert seit der vergangenen woche die
krone situation ist immer noch
dramatisch also das wird er nicht
passieren genau es war die klasse g 9
ades zabel gymnasiums nürnberg um das
auch noch nachzuschieben nicole
theoretisch kann er jetzt heute auch
schon die erste kabinettssitzung statt
finden wenn die ministerinnen und
minister dann auch später vereidigt sind
wird es passieren
theoretisch kann sie das heute werden
auch die ersten übergaben stattfinden
zum beispiel zwischen angela merkel und
olaf scholz
aber soweit ich das weiß
mit dieser einschränkung muss ich das
sagen wird auch morgen noch miteinander
gesprochen zwischen amtsvorgängern und
neuen amtsinhabern also von daher
man nähert sich mit großen schritten den
letzten schritten auf der zielgeraden
aber
die ämter sind noch nicht inhaltlich
wirklich übergeben also genau dass es
stand jetzt
wir senden seit heute morgen um viertel
vor neun mittlerweile ist es fast zehn
nach zwölf das ist schon eine ganze
weile es ist aber natürlich auch eine
ganze menge passiert heute morgen und
das haben wir jetzt zusammengefasst es
schon mal zu machen
liebe gäste sehr verehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen einen
schönen guten morgen die sitzung ist
eröffnet
ich begrüße auf der ehrentribüne die
geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin frau
dr angela merkel
damit rufe ich den tagesordnungspunkt 2
auf die wahl des bundeskanzlers der herr
bundespräsident hat mir hierzu
mitgeteilt gemäß artikel 63 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland schlage ich dem deutschen
bundestag vor herrn olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler zu wählen
ich gebe das ergebnis
bekannt mitgliederzahl
736 abgegebene stimmen
ungültige stimmzettel 3
mit ja haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete
vielen dank wir können das gleich
weitermachen aber ich wollte noch das
andere die anderen stimmt zahlen bekannt
geben mit nein haben gestimmt
363 hat die erforderliche mehrheit von
mindestens
369 stimmen erreicht er ist gemäß
artikel 63 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
zum bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt
jetzt kommt aber die alles entscheidende
frage ich frage sie herr abgeordneter
scholz nehmen sie die wahl an
das war laut und vernehmlich herr
bundeskanzler
ich gratuliere ihnen den namen des
ganzen hauses zu ihrer wahl auch
persönlich wünsche ich ihnen viel kraft
für die vor ihnen liegenden aufgaben und
das ergebnis der wahl werde ich jetzt
unverzüglich dem herrn bundespräsidenten
mitteilen
im namen der bundesrepublik deutschland
ähnlich aufgrund des artikels 63 absatz
2 satz 2 des grundgesetzes für die
bundesrepublik deutschland herrn olaf
scholz zum bundeskanzler berlin den 8
dezember 2021
der bundespräsident und die unterschrift
herr bundeskanzler man ganz herzlichen
glückwunsch
sollten wir die glaube ich noch mal
aufgeklappt in die kamera
so das war jetzt war sie kanzlerwahl
ernennung im schnelldurchlauf
tatsächlich hat das prozedere etwa drei
stunden gedauert und nicole und ich
haben das zusammen gemacht dafür vielen
dank schon mal nicole vielleicht jetzt
noch einmal einen kurzen ausblick als
letzte frage du hast ja schon gesagt
diese 100 tage schonfrist
die gibt es diesmal so nicht das kann
sich das land in der aktuellen krone
situation einfach nicht leisten was
passiert jetzt konkrete in den nächsten
tagen
in den nächsten tagen sind hier
sondersitzung angesetzt das zeigt
tatsächlich diese ausnahme situation
in der olaf scholz und sein kabinett
hier die macht übernehmen in deutschland
morgen zweite und dritte lesung hier im
bundestag infektionsschutzgesetz an dem
was an dass man schon wieder ran geht
muss man sagen dass nachgeschärft wird
und am freitag dann ebenfalls
sondersitzung im bundesrat wo man diese
änderungen unter anderem eine
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht dann
beschließen will also corona ist das
alles beherrschende thema wir haben das
auch in den letzten zwei wochen gesehen
seit verabschiedung beziehungsweise seit
präsentation des koalitionsvertrages ja
klar haben wir uns da in den nachrichten
mit beschäftigt aber
man kommt nicht dran vorbei das thema
ist dieser pandemie ist diese
entsetzliche vierte welle in der wir
hier in deutschland im moment stecken
und das gilt nicht nur für uns das gilt
nicht nur für uns als journalistinnen
und journalisten das geht nicht das wird